seat pink cards to representative
way couple of announcements as we get
going first of all you will notice in
the
calendar you will notice in the calendar
There Are No Children and Family Law
bills on consent and there are no
children and family laws on the regular
calendar but uh as was once
said in other words wait till next week
it's all going to hit um also I want to
thank thank people for taking to Heart
the exhortation that if you were to
write a committee report you would get
it to the
clerk that day before you leave that
expedites the routing as it comes to me
for editing it goes to the clerk it goes
to the committee assistant it goes over
to the clerk of the houses office and I
want to thank you because everybody
except one
got the report in on
time and you know it's funny
um Kevin landrian who is the political
writer for the union leader had the next
a couple days later about how the bill
passed with amendment in
committee they said did we pass that
through you know I was sitting over
there and and you know all my wisdom is
over here so I didn't know anything
about that so I made a few calls and
said yeah you don't you remember the
amendment passed we EXA it whoops so I
get the report in a day late and I I'll
you I open the uh hearing on House Bill
1261 relative to voluntary Services
Under The Chins program and the chair
recognizes representative Ved Castile to
US Representative long Vice chairman
job
good morning uh I'll open house bill
1261 relative to voluntary Services
good okay they're all friends so I'm
random the chair recognizes Jason Taylor
and he lists his address as Lisa massio
which is actually his next door neighbor
right there and they are from the office
of the child advocate and they will be
1261 good morning chairman paron and the
committee I am attorney Lisa masio the
associate child advocate with the office
of child advocate and I have with me one
of our assistant child advocates in the
Ombudsman role Jason Taylor um we just
wanted to give you all a little bit of
context and background um we weren't
involved with the drafting of this bill
but this is an issue that we see fairly
frequently at our office and are hopeful
that the language in this bill will
allow for some additional um services to
be provided for children um I'm going to
let Jason take the lead on this one
because he has been in the field for a
long time and is actively working on
several cases related to this
spell good morning Mr chairman thank you
so much I'm happy to answer questions as
well um we have taken a look at the
language in the bill and um in terms of
working with teenagers which has been
the majority of my career both uh for
DCF and at snoooo Center as well as in
the mental health field uh a child's
reluctance to treatment is Paramount in
many many cases that we see uh in fact I
I would say many high-profile cases in
our state uh have been riddled with
reluctance on the part of the child to
receive Services many many times we see
that in in and I think that's I would
say that a child a teenage child's
behavior is maybe as predictable as the
weather here in New England that we're
seeing these days so um a child's
refusal to accept Services is more
common than a child that's willing to
work with anyone especially in this age
range especially a child that is being
considered for any type typ of uh State
service so that was a primary concern um
we had mentioned this morning as well
that we've seen many post- adopt cases
that have come in very caring families
that have adopted children from the
system the child uh is not eligible for
an abuse neglect case because the
parents are of course trying to get the
child help the child is very um
reluctant to work with anyone especially
anyone with DCF attached to them and
we're seeing those children um having a
hard time entering Services uh including
sometimes fastforward referrals are made
uh from a DCF worker and the family in
some cases does not engage with those
services so just I think Building Things
based on a child's willingness to enter
mental health treatment or any type of
services is a slippery slope and we feel
that it will um it will take Services
away from children that that otherwise
need it uh and lastly I would just say
that in many of these cases the parents
are very motivated to get the child help
and we want to you know the parents to
be able to make those decisions that
their child requires that and not base a
child's services on what they're willing
to do because many of them are not
services and we just wanted um looking
at the language of this particular Bill
and again we didn't work with the
sponsors on this but if you read how the
language is currently the current way it
works is that refusal of the child to
participate in the development of a
voluntary family service plan or um with
the
Department May constitute sufficient
information for them to say we're not
going to help the families typically the
parents who are asking for voluntary
chins which is a child in need of
services saying we really need help for
our child they're having trouble dealing
with their child probably a stranger
coming into the home might initially
have trouble as well so this new
language really just makes it clear that
that initial refusal or reluctance which
is normal particularly for a child that
has a significant amount of trauma
shouldn't be the sole basis for this
decision going forward of like we're not
going to offer
services again there could be other
reasons why they may not offer services
but we have seen cases where it's just
kind of a hard no because this kid's
hard to work with even if the family is
still desperately asking for help we see
this in Ed boarding cases as well I know
there's been a lot of talk in this
committee about those cases parents
desperately trying to get their children
help it is very hard to get into the
system and we'd really rather not see a
kid have to go through 169b which is
Juvenile Justice wait till they do
something that there's charges being
filed for the Department to feel able or
willing to provide services because as
much as we want a kid in whatever door
they need to be the Juvenile Justice
door should really be The Last Choice so
by building this into 169 D which is
that children in need of services can be
voluntary we think we just offer
additional ability for the division to
be able to offer services because
sometimes it's even the service provider
doing the assessment or in there saying
oh the kid said no we're done so we are
hopeful that this language and obviously
if there's you know questions or
amendments to be made but we think this
door is important to crack open for kids
because we've seen what happens when
it's not in other words one strike in
your route is off the
books we hope so that this language
would accomplished this
yes any questions representative
long thank you Mr chairman uh so my
concern is uh if a child refuses
service is reluctant when he's forced
into that service is not going
to you know is not going to help the
child um so is there any consideration
for that I'll let Jason talk about what
trauma and behaviors typically look
like well I think that most children
when they hear counseling or any type of
service anything on paper there's
definitely some reluctance I think it's
just incumbent upon the provider to find
inroads with that child I think also
depending on the level of trauma that
the child may have experienced uh under
no circumstances will they agree to
almost anything but if it is in the best
interest and it's a prevention measure
to keep that child either out of
placement out of the hospital or out of
unsafe
situations I think it's a fair trade but
I do I certainly uh respect your your
thoughts uh representative long about
you know sort of wanting that to engage
the child but I think that a skilled
provider uh should be able to do that
and convince the child of the value uh
again with things like out of home
placement or delinquency or other
stronger consequences that may be sort
of on the horizon for these children you
have to find a way to get them in um you
know I like to believe I can get in any
room and have any child talk to me uh
that's been my history I don't really
know how that happens or why that
happens but trying to convince them and
and sometimes it's a strategy about you
know convincing them to do what they're
willing to do it may not be everything
that we want but with the importance of
prevention and again you know we're
we're very big on trying to keep kids
out of the system in a more intrusive
way I think that that's where you have
the tra off here is is trying to
convince a child let's get you some help
and some Services now before things go
down this other road which you will lose
a lot of control uh both as a child and
a parent once the child goes into the
system and just to add
the this is really just more trauma
informed Language by recognizing that a
child is likely to have an initial
refusal or reluctance in addition under
voluntary chins the whole family
potentially is receiving services in
their home
which is a wraparound so the parents may
even just be able to get some benefit
from some coaching learning what the
resources are so it's more than just
forcing a kid to do therapy when they're
saying no there's a lot of other pieces
of services as we build out this
children's Behavioral Health System that
could help a
family
followup uh thank you Mr chairman uh
follow up on this um I you know I'm a
firm believer in giving youth choices
because once they accept the choice
so I mean I'm thinking that there are
alternatives if you don't agree you're
going to be placed wherever or you're G
to be going into the judicial system um
is that is that a high number uh that
are faced with those questions you
either get placed out of your your home
or you go into the court system or you
service I
would I would say absolutely um that
comes up quite a bit I think
that sometimes we get to those steps
without trying the things before we see
many children entering the most you know
the most restrictive level of care um
having never experienced intensive
inhome supports and there are in
placement so I think if you have an
opportunity to talk to a child and talk
them through hey like we can start you
know down here and give you this support
so that we don't end up there we don't
always have that luxury as a system um
especially with kids you know if they're
involved in a serious crime uh folks are
not generally looking to keep the child
in the home at that point uh the parents
may not feel safe depending on the age
and situation of the child so I I would
love to have that opportunity more than
I think we sometimes do sometimes we do
skip right to the most you know serious
type of situations and we always look at
what you know what prevention was there
um you know just anecdotally if you look
at the kids that are currently uh at snu
Center um over my time there which was
there for about three years you know
probably high 80% of those kids had you
know 20 30 Child Protection referrals
before they entered Juvenile Justice you
know that that were not necessarily
long-term involvement you know talking
90 days of sort of looking is key abuse
neglect issues that can prevent stronger
intervention uh and those were closed
and then you know you see these things
kind of when you don't find the right
services at the right time for a child
before they get older we we don't always
have the ability to to go that route so
it it's a difficult thing to sort of
nail down but ultimately prevention um
and getting to to Children sooner with
the services and support uh will
hopefully prevent those things from
going down that road just one more one
more thank you uh so uh so I look at the
initial refusal so in this case if this
were to pass I refuse as a child I go to
my first court date and it's like yeah I
don't like this um can I accept the
voluntary services or is it too late or
or I'm placed out of placement I don't
like where I
am um could I say well wait a minute I
want to go I I accept the services
because this is initial I think the idea
of the language in this bill and again I
haven't spoken to the sponsor
is at that initial refusal if the family
is still saying we want a voluntary
chins which is a a voluntary pre- Court
situation that the service providers
will still stay in there complete the
assessment offer what they can that that
initial I don't want this is not the end
and routes then directly into JJ J or
placement it's really just to and again
it's the sole decision there may be
other things going on that they're like
sorry we the voluntary chins isn't going
to work but we do feel like this extra
sentence opens that door to not just
take that initial refusal and say okay
you're going to 169b court over there
and maybe allow a little bit of
breathing room like Jason said if you
get a provider in there that's willing
to develop a relationship with that
child with that family through the
course of the assessments get some
services in place it may not be
everything we avoid that whole process
Al together okay thank you I'm going to
take representative Greg out of order
here thank you Mr chairman I appreciate
that and thank you for taking my
question so just to kind of simplify it
and knowing that if we understand that
traumatized children uh struggle with
trust and that certainly on those first
you know touches we're going to you're
you're just trying to build trust and
stuff would the language in this allow
you cuz I'm I'm looking at how this you
know came about before and how they were
doing it before and and knowing that
these kids are going to struggle to
trust would this just open that door for
you to build trust a little more to kind
of not make them do these things but
just to be able to um have them
understand more that this is you you
want what's good for them and not you
know more of a punishment is that what
language like this would do that is our
hope and our read of this language that
that is what they are trying to do yes
okay again some of it has to do with how
the division ultimately implements the
language but I think that is the problem
this language is trying to get to and I
think it's worded in a way that that is
what that means to me okay thank you
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um so my my question is a
little bit similar to uh representative
Greg's where I'm I'm wondering if you
have experience um my background is as a
nurse and sometimes with like dementia
patients they they refuse a lot of
things but you you bu trust like like
like representative Greg was saying and
then they ultimately accept so I'm
wondering if you have any type of
experience in any capacity of kids who
have initially refused but then
ultimately accepted but maybe you
haven't because this bill is not in
effect yet so I'm G to let Jason give
you an actual example but I will say
just generally speaking there's a lot of
our laws that recognize that the parents
actually are supposed to be in charge so
the fact that this get get interpreted
that a child's initial reluctance means
the family asking for help under a
voluntary chins gets a hard pass is a
dilemma again that hopefully this
language is hoping to address of like
but the parents are still asking for
help they need help I will let Jason
answer your specific question because I
examples so um thank you for your
question I would just say that quite
honestly the child has some discretion
until they don't until the intervention
is put down through court orders and we
see them go into you know a system in a
in a in a way that they don't have any
choice so in order to to do what you're
implying which is sort of getting them
to to buy in you have to sort of have
that conversation about about it and it
it is a nuanced thing and I and I agree
with what Lisa had said in terms of the
parents I think sometimes as a
professional you have to work with the
parents they know their child best
they're asking for help some of them are
begging help and they've they feel that
they've tried everything they can use in
their toolbox so once they're connected
with providers they can also show their
child they're working on things and be a
participant in the case as well and I
would also just mention that you know if
if a child goes through the wrong door
and enters into the system DCF has every
opportunity to close cases and to to
send the family to other service
providers if they feel it does not meet
their need so you know I don't know that
the danger of this is you know doing too
little for a child it's it's almost like
a child could be sort of evaluated to
need more and then once the family
starts doing some work you see
improvements and the child can leave you
know so I think that the value far
outweighs the danger of of it going down
the wrong path but yes children are very
resistant to counseling and services um
you know I typically believe in sort of
building children up with sports and
activities and doing all those other
things too so I think that if there's
other things you can offer in addition
to you know a counselor intervention
that the child doesn't want uh sometimes
that can help as well but and I don't
believe in threatening children but they
do need to understand that their choices
will go away when they enter the system
in a in a more intrusive way and the
family um typically does not want that
and we usually advise them against that
if at all possible so this is a way to
um to try to prevent them from getting
caught up in the system and missing
school and doing you know the things
that we see the pitfalls of all of that
representative D
Simone thank you Mr chairman uh my
question is in line with the the last
two if you please uh is it your opinion
through your experience
that the analogy of leading the
proverbial horse to the water uh they'll
get parched enough where eventually
they'll start to drink they'll start to
trust they'll start to recognize and
will this uh the language in this bill
help to bridge that
Gap we we believe so that the way it is
written and the intent behind it is to
do that to not just take the initial no
and walk away but to keep
dry thank
you representative ball thank you
chairman peon and thank you for for all
your hard work and um and for taking my
question when I was a teacher I was um
certified as an emotional behavioral
specialists and I did have children that
um were on chins and also some that were
just court involved um that required me
to go to the courts is that still the
system do you still work with wraparound
districts absolutely I think when the
state becomes involved with the child um
the goal should be to pull in everybody
that has information about the child uh
increased communication and work
together um that's that's essentially
you know I think that um one of the
biggest things that that I see with with
kids coming into the system is is again
making sure that everyone's on the same
page and working together to prevent
things from going down a dangerous path
um I I would also just say that you know
in terms of like children's resistance I
mean that's also a way um to bring
people in if they do have people people
they trust at school um you know
sometimes I'll ask to go meet with a
child uh in my previous career um with a
school professional or guidance
counselor to sort of soften that
introduction when I was a DCF worker um
I think that relationships go a long way
and so you have to just be I
think sometimes you have to convince a
child to do something uh for a variety
of reasons and and use a different
methods But ultimately with this people
that they trust absolutely you'd want to
collaborate with those folks and get the
information in terms of what they
believe the child's need is uh School
professionals as we saw during covid
have a ton of information regarding how
a child functions at school um and so so
we would absolutely always want to get
that information in order to do our jobs
better and that is one of the advantages
of our office the office of child
advocate being a sort of independent
oversight agency is we get calls from
all different angles from within the
system from within the school and
sometimes our role is just bringing all
those players together to the same table
so we do have sort of a a broader view
sometimes of these cases than just the
worker from the division might have or
just the teacher might have so um that
is sort of one of the advantages of the
work we're able to do thank you very
much I do appreciate all you do and it
does take a village to raise um our
children and um again thank you so much
service no further hands seeing no
further hands thank thank you very much
Taylor attorney Susan larabe newly
Minted as DCF General councel says she
is here to provide any information as
needed since spring training starts
tomorrow I've got a few baseball
questions for you but I'll defer to
anybody who wants to actually speak
bill
I apologize I'm still getting used to
this good morning everybody I again
Susan larab be general counsel for DCF I
am here to answer any questions and to
maybe also go through the chins process
with everybody and the in the Statue
itself I think there was some um maybe
misunderstanding that this is about
chins pursuant to 169 d a child in need
of services
um and if you look at the Statue as a
whole many of what has been discussed
already is already embedded into the
statute for the various reasons we we
know and we've talked about children
change their minds all the time
especially adolesence and that is built
into the
statute where it says I apologize in uh
169 DB a voluntary service plan at any
time before after a petition is filed
the child his or her caretaker and the
department may effectuate an individual
voluntary family service plan which
shall include and goes over the elements
of what to include in a voluntary
service plan which would result in the
case being as it says in the in the
statute um stayed for a period of 90
days because we know again the first
time that this comes into DCF for an
assessment and the uh if it meets the
definition of again not a 169b case
which is delinquency which is again if a
child engages in what would be a felony
or misdemeanor in the adult world that
is delinquency this is a Chin's petition
a child in need of services who is
either a habitual runaway habitually
truant repeatedly engaging in violations
or what's called a 2d case a child based
on their I should should read this uh by
quoting it because it is a very a
detailed part of the statue with the
diagnosis diagnosis of severe emotional
cognitive or other mental health issues
who engage in aggressive fire setting or
sexualized behavior that pose a danger
to the child or others and who is
otherwise unable or ineligible for
services under 169 B or C and those are
the definitions of the chin statue when
that comes into dcyf for an assessment
that juvenile probation parole officer
as a case worker engages the family to
try to do a voluntary Service uh plan in
lie of instead of bringing the court the
case to court through a Chin's petition
and a Chin's petition can be brought by
a parent it can be brought by law
enforcement it can be bought brought by
a truant
officer to avoid that of course we want
the child and the parent to be engaging
with DCF to engage in a voluntary
service plan and by definition the word
voluntary means that it's something that
both the parent and the child want if
that is not the case and the child says
I don't want to engage in a voluntary
service plan then the option is for the
person who originally called that case
in to then petition the court for an
actual Chin's case and within the chin
Chin's petition itself the Chin's
petition must State how voluntary
Services have been attempted and why
there is not a
voluntary uh service case plan
executed when it gets set then for court
based on that petition if the kid comes
in and that time the kid also gets
assigned counil to also represent the
child's best interest so if the parent
and and the child are not seeing eye to
eye there's also now an outside counsel
who
can uh explain more about the voluntary
service plan as well to a child or an
adolescent who may be reluctant to
engage and like I said it's already part
of the statute that if that happens we
can all agree in terms of DCF the court
the parents the family the defense
attorney I'm sorry the juveniles
attorney
that this case should be placed on file
it should be stayed remove from the
court calendar because now we have a kid
who wants to engage in the process so
bottom line the the wording of the bill
is already embedded into other sections
of the 169 D chins
you am I the only one that thinks we're
really overthinking this it is very
simple to me but then again um that
we're just saying one strike you're not
out anymore you can come back again
that's it period which is written with
very specific um instructions to the
court when that happens place the uh the
voluntary service plan shall stay the
proceedings for a period not to exceed
90 days from the date of implementation
unless the parties agree in writing for
an extension um and then ultimately the
voluntary family service plan will
suspend the proceedings if the child
satisfies the terms of the voluntary
family service plan he or she shall be
discharged from further services or
supervision and the pending complaint or
petition shall be dismissed with
prejudice again because we all want the
same exactly not without prejudice with
prejudice because we all want the same
thing we all want the child to receive
services and we want the child to be
volunt terly brought into the process
representative
long thank you Mr chairman uh does
anybody
know how many cases this affects how
many uh what percent of cases are are uh
formed by the child's initial refusal I
don't have that data I mean is it a lot
know
OCA okay you don't have members for that
OCA attest they do not have numbers to
that thank you just a follow follow so
with respect to the 90 days am I getting
this right um under
69d there is 90 days so if I'm sent to
JJ in a month goes by and I decide as a
youth that I'll take these voluntary
Services there's a stay in the court and
there's there's 90 days that that could
happen there's 90 days that we have
agreed by agreement to the court to take
it off the court calendar for 90 days
and within that time if the juvenile
then once again says you know I don't
want to participate in this voluntary
process or they go to a a a a child
adolescent needs assessment um interview
to find out what kind of plan that is
right for this child if something goes
south so to speak then yes it can be
brought back onto the calendar within
that 90 days if it's not it
automatically will get dismissed at the
end of those 90 days pursuant to the
last part of that statute okay if the if
the child satisfied the terms of the
voluntary service plan he will be
discharged from further uh services and
the complaint will be dismissed followup
representative long yeah I'm trying to
figure out this initial
refusal passing this bill what effect it
would have negative l i in your opinion
does initial
refusal take get rid of that 90day thing
because now we're talking initial no I
think what it does is that it gets rid
of that
initial need to f i the way I read it
and again I I'm not sure again uh we're
overthinking it init the word initial is
what I'm because initial that happens
all the time and that's why it's been
already put into this other subsection
saying if a kiddo changes their mind
fine that's great um so I don't know if
that means if there's an initial refusal
but the parent and the juvenile
probation officer still believes that
voluntary services in their is in their
child in the child's best interest that
becomes imposed on them imposed on the
child there but again therefore how is
that voluntary the term voluntary has to
be voluntary for the parent the child
and the juvenile probation officer and
it says and inscribing it representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here and explaining and taking
my question so back to um I'm sure you
heard me ask that question so you know
we start started by saying that we
understand that these kids you know
probably have a lack of trust and that
we're trying to build trust what we
currently have in statute says that if
they
um if they refuse then we do go into the
courts in this 90day thing however with
this particular Amendment we're saying
you know what we understand that they're
probably going to say no so let us build
trust with them and do that and I do you
not feel that that's that's not forcing
them that's building taking a moment to
build that trust rather than threatening
them and saying we're going straight to
court now and we have a 90day a leeway
but we're basically threatening is that
what is that what you're saying I
absolutely agree and that's why I did um
in my the way my brain works I wrote
down language I thought might be clear
to me as a reader of the bill and I just
said that the child initial reluctance
Andor refusal to participate in a
voluntary Services assessment should not
be the sole reason to not engage and
assess if voluntary service is otherwise
appropriate and in the best interest of
the child because I think the way it
reads is that the assessment worker may
go to the house start talking to the
child and the child says no I'm not
interested and that without that
language proposed that means the
assessment worker could leave and then
recommend that a Chin's petition be
filed so this is saying that if a child
initially says no further Engage The
child work with the child before making
that final determination uh that a
Chin's petition can be filed because
again it's not the JJ assessment worker
who's bringing the petition it's either
law enforcement the treny officer the
school or the parent they're just giving
the acknowledgement pursuant to the way
the statute
reads um any petition filed shall
include language demonstrating whether
appropriate voluntary services have been
attempted the nature of voluntary
service attempted and the reason Court
compulsion is necessary so that's
already part of the statue and it's
already embedded into the the petition
for a chins um as as it is already
representative Greg followup I'm just
wondering then are you for this bill or
are you not for this bill because the
explanation you just gave sounded like
you you see the necessity of explaining
it this way in this bill so I maybe I'm
I guess I'm not for the way the bill
read the four corners of the bill the
exact language of that
wording we are not for because I think
it leads to a lot of uh interpretation
that a child can be
plan is it true to say you like the
general idea the concept but the wording
would as we know sometimes if it's uous
any reasonable person can come up with
several different conclusions and the
concept is already in practice and it's
in policy and it's already again written
that a JJ assessment worker goes and
engages with the family as part of the
assessment
Panic so you're saying this bill is not
necessary because it's duplicating what
we already have absolutely and it's
already in language of various
subsections of the Chin's petition for
that very reason that kids change their
mind it's in various sections because it
happens at different times it could even
happen post what we called adjudication
where right before a disposition hey can
we come to consent can there be an
agreement so there's many different
steps of the legal process and that's
why it's written in so many different
subsections of the chin and it is in the
Chin's petition I mean in the chin
statute that a child may change their
mind at any time thank
you seeing nothing further I do want to
call uh
what oh sorry representative
brickford thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for coming
um it's it's in the it's in the Chin's
statutes the stin statutes were had a
major
overhaul some years ago uh on
them and I thought they had it
right
and is it possible that you're just not
it's not happening in practice even
though it's in statute it's not
happening in
practice and no matter what you right
here may not work if if the Department's
not doing it doing what's written here
to do and I I know you fairly knew but
you might want to check that out as to
why they're the bill came
forward thank you sure thank you
representative deimon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and all you
do is it your
opinion that the language in this bill
will
not in any way enhance the current
Chin's language
exactly and it would actually be less um
focused on the needs the rights the
independence of the child by having a
Services thank you for your testimony
I've been watching OCA over there and uh
I would like to invite you back thank
you for your testimony I would like to
invite you back very briefly uh on the
necessary thank you representative
Pearson that is a very pointed question
it was a leading question Council it was
and and representative Bickford I really
appreciate your question because I think
what we see in practice every day
including a lot of cases in a last few
months where kids are getting routed to
Juvenile Justice prosecution rather than
being given services that the family is
desperately begging for is a serious
problem that is currently happening
under the law right now under the
policies under current practice so we do
think there is an issue if attorney
larabie feels the language she read out
which I didn't catch every word of said
better what this is trying to say we are
all for that but in current practice
under the way the statute is currently
written this is happening and I
appreciate a child can't be forced to
engage but I don't think that's what
this language is trying to do it is
trying to Simply preempt the you said no
we're done go to court which is what is
happening and also we have lots of laws
that Force children to do lots of things
because under 169c and 169b they don't
have a choice
anymore there is a trauma response and a
behavioral response for teenagers that
is normal y thank you uh I'm not well I
guess I am representative Nelson not
Nelson representative hang on
Raymond thank you Mr chairman I
appreciate your Indulgence um I have a
question
about um the representation for the
child um in the difference between like
a voluntary case as we're talking about
here and a core ordered case because
current practice is now you the the
worker goes out they talk to the the
child and the family the family thinks
the child need Services the child is not
interested and then the next step is to
go to court at which time the child gets
an attorney or a a guardian ad liem
something thank you for that question
that is a great point and we do
appreciate that within 169b cases that
are filed a child is assigned counsel in
a 169 D chins case that is filed so not
the voluntary case you're correct right
they do get an attorney in a 169c case
there is a bill pending currently they
don't get an attorney right um the role
of the attorney is very important we
would love for all kids to have
attorneys however the danger and the
slippery slope that Jason talked about
earlier is once that child is in a court
proceeding it can be very very hard to
get out of that Court proceeding yes
they have the option to dismiss it and I
don't have the statistics of how often
that happens but again as Jason said
earlier a voluntary J chins pre any
filing at all is completely voluntary
but if you had to file first and now you
switch to a voluntary there's still a
court proceeding happening it can get
out of that child in that family's
control very quickly a voluntary chin
pre- Court would avoid that although we
do love when kids get counsel and can
tell them they I'm going to call on one
more person and then I'm going to close
the hearing representative D Simon thank
you Mr chairman and thank you again for
all you do and taking my question I'm
going to ask you the same question so is
it your opinion that this bill will
enhance
169 we believe that language this
language or the language that attorney
larab be offered would add another layer
of trauma informed knowledge and
protection for children yes thank you
and thank you for coming back and uh
this will conclude the hearing on House
Bill 1261 and uh OCA likes DHHS does not
um we've never faced this
before I'm only kidding um it does bring
a breath to the subject so we will not
be executing this bill today and um
members of the committee feel free to
contact either or
both um sets of of people here um as we
come to whatever conclusion we're going
to come to when we do execute so thank
you
everybody now if somebody sees
representative McGuff outside he's up
next with his bill I saw him snatch a
pink
fun
there
for
chair recognizes The Honorable gentleman
from Hillsboro 12 which is my avoidance
of mispronouncing your name an act
relative to the use of child restraints
in schools help me please
thank you Mr chairman it's
representative MCU Tim MCU from the town
of MCU got it thank you yeah not at all
like it looks there was an Ian there at
one point I guess okay anyhow I'm Tim
MCU I represent the town of marac
Hillsboro County District 12 and I'm
here to talk to you today about
increasing a little bit of transparency
and doing whatever we can to open some
lines of communications clear up
questions that happen when child
children students in our schools are
restrained
yes restrained believe it or not so the
bill proposes some crucial modifications
to 126 which relate to the condition of
seclusions and restraints and and I know
the committee is somewhat familiar
because last year we passed um a couple
of things one was to Outlaw prone
restraints and one was to clarify the
reporting form to make it a little more
Universal and that has worked
well but when I learned that there had
been 1,000
434 instances where students were
restrained against their will spe
specifically in do there were 202 cases
nashille Broad Street School
169 with Hanover Danville and Hudson
rounding out the top
five I thought you know this is uh
pretty astonishing and we need to do
something about it or at least have a
look into it so look into it we did a
constituent brought this information to
me uh she's here with some of her uh
colleagues and friends who will tell you
their stories as well um so myself and
the other marac Representatives got
together met with the school dist
District to see what was happening in
marac and we found out that they had
already documented 49 cases of restraint
now as I'm sure this knowledgeable
committee knows restraint can be fair
Fairly wide variety of practices from
handholding you know sort of placing arm
on the elbow I mean I think you get the
idea it runs the full gamut and I think
you already are pretty familiar with
with it so with 49 cases and this many
cases we did question how many of those
are the same student and how many of of
them are the most severe and that's
virtually impossible to tell um how you
know unless you unless the doe and those
were doe figures unless you went through
and tried to parse them out and call
them out but one thing that you could do
is utilize what's already in 189 I think
it's 18
18968 the IEP uh and it might be D or C
or D or something it's pretty far down
on that long list of things uh you can
utilize audiovisual recording already
and this puts that utilization ability
into the seclusion statute right um with
the appropriate guard rails so that you
know you don't have to set up a camera
and a and a boom mic uh at the first
sign of trouble right obviously that's
completely impractical safety first um I
give you a little bit of of my own
background I'm 30 years a paramedic and
I've dealt with hundreds of hostile
patients both adults and children um
from the you know PhD Professor that
everybody loves that we found uh naked
in his front yard you know beating the
heck out of the police officers and I
mean beating the heck out of them this
is before the days of non-lethal uh
things and it was up to us to restrain
them chemically uh so I've pretty much
seen the gamut and including teaching
the gold standard crisis censor
intervention and deescalation courses at
the University level so this is a a
subject that I'm pretty familiar with
what I wasn't familiar with was how
often it happens in the schools to our
kids and that padded rooms exist in many
many schools that was new to
me uh so when we looked into it a little
bit further despite the improvements
made last year in the reporting
requirements and the prohibition of
prone restraints there the issue still
persists and it happens just too often
in in New Hampshire in New Hampshire
schools so I think this bill is a good
step forward towards addressing those
transparency concerns especially for the
non-verbal patient that comes home and
tells mom and dad or the guardian what
happened and they have a difficulty
communicating exactly what happened um
one case we heard about um such a
student who is less communicative at
least in
school uh claimed to have been treated
fairly harshly and restrained harshly
and secluded they reviewed the hallway
camera and that was not at all the case
this the staff were completely
appropriate had not laid a hand on them
so it really works both ways and it
truly does because I I if I had to guess
from the research I've done it's not
50/50 but there's a pretty significant
percentage of time when the stories
don't match up well this recording on
YouTube there's not going to be any
doubt what I said to you today right no
no doubt I mean it is a very very
clear uh way to preserve evidence and to
help open those lines of
communication so that's what the bill
does and I'm happy to take any questions
and let you hear from the folks behind
us who have plenty to tell you
representative
Panic thank you Mr chairman I worked as
a special needs uh um par educator quite
a few years ago and the population that
I worked
with um in Special Needs involves some
of the
violent there was a lot of violence and
you could be in a very quiet classroom
and then all of a sudden a student would
jump out of its seat out of his seat and
start attacking another student
representative move to a question please
okay
this bill is asking to put in uh Rec
recording
materials um to record the restraining
process you can't set that up so are you
is this setting up the scenario to have
maybe video recorders like they do with
the police department on the teachers
and the teachers AIDS thank you
representative pic for your question um
fascinating idea no I hadn't thought of
that I wouldn't be surprised if in some
of those most serious violent situations
that a
responding administrator might choose to
come equipped with body cams if the
school decides to do that that's not
specifically in here in fact there's
specific I think I mentioned them guard
rails about as soon as practical and
safety is first like deescalation
deregulation get to a safe place some of
that is first if it's practical uh and I
don't think it will be difficult to
determine whether it's practical because
there's a fairly extensive form that you
fill out detailing that everybody fills
out so you have several versions of it
um the detailing exactly what happened
so I think it's then it's it will be
possible to tell whether it was
practical or not the emphasis um for
this is also on exclusion or a seclusion
sorry not every uh Place had from what I
understand has audio video monitoring uh
they should have at a minimum one: one
monitoring and should be able to see the
secluded student at all times um but if
there were uh if there was audio video
monitoring even just somebody's cell
phone not someone's personal cell phone
don't worry I'm not suggesting that
staff be told to use their personal cell
phones but I I think it's a a manageable
we worked we went around around a bit on
the language to make it specific and and
narrow and uh
implementable does this speak to the
question of each School having a special
room already set up for the video and
the unruly person would be taken to that
or
given the variety of how this might
occur do are you contemplating uh video
recordings in each
room so I I am am contemplating that U
there should be audio video recording in
each seclusion room I think many of them
already have that some of the experts
that have been into many more of them
than I have uh we'll be able to speak to
that also what we found is there's a lot
of hallway cameras and common area
cameras these days
um and uh so that those are those are
useful they're really not part of the
bill because the
IEP nothing nothing in the the languages
nothing in this passage shall preclude
the use of audiovisual instruction in
the course of or audiovisual monitoring
in the course of instruction that's the
IEP language what what this bill does is
lets a parent request that be utilized
in the event of a restraining or
secluding type
situation representative D Simon thank
you Mr chairman thank you for bringing
this to us in taking my
question um starting on line 22 it read
your bill reads as soon as practical
pursuant to RSA 189 col 68 each use of
restraint shall be visually and
auditorally recorded if such method of
recording is included in the students
indivi
individualized education program or
accommodation plan who makes that
decision as to who shall and who shall
recorded the parent the parent makes the
AP thank you so is this the case that
students in general this does not apply
to only those with
IEPs am I reading it that right yes I
believe you are okay thank you yeah uh
representative panic and then thank you
Mr chairman uh one more question uh so
these students that have IEP they they
are obviously blended into a regular uh
classroom um the sometimes the restraint
has to happen
immediately so you can't go out there
and start setting up cameras and
everything else
so what is your proposal for something
like that I mean what is this spill
cover thank you for uh helping me
clarify uh because the bill does cover
that I mentioned a couple of times uh in
the in first sentence as soon as
practicable right which so so that
already puts that guard rail uh and I
think it's important that there be
flexibility for the teachers and the
administrators they have to protect
themselves I've been you know smacked in
the face once by someone who I thought
was unconscious in the middle of a
frozen lake uh I'm I'm now much more
hand aware uh in approaching an
unconscious patient so you know Safety
First and I think that allows that as
soon as practicable so initial Outburst
may be the most or at least one of the
more violent parts of the episode and so
you've got to get this person restrained
immediately uh so that part of the
encounter possibly would not be recorded
indeed yeah and and I don't I don't have
the answer for that actually thank you
representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question I just need some clarification
students with IEPs are mainstreamed and
they're in the general population does
this mean that students with IEPs um you
would have to have Visual and auditory
recordings in every single classroom in
the building to accommodate those
students so in effect every classroom
would have to have these recording
devices thank you for the question repo
represent patrino that's a that's a good
question um and the answer is no I don't
don't think so um but we are not looking
to reinvent the IEP statute that already
exists right the the language is
specific
in
189 uh way down at the
bottom
9 68 VD actually it might be VC in fact
that could be a typo um that
specifically says nothing in this
passage shall preclude the use of audio
visual
recording so when representative Mooney
and I were word smithing it with some of
the SAU staff that was the uh between
the three of us four of us and OLS it
appeared to be the best utilization of
language representative Raymond thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question my
question is in regards to how this bill
would interact with the uh furpa
standard so the federal uh federal
education privacy records act so
students have rights to privacy and So
currently under furpa if you have
multiple students engaged in an incident
that has caught on film all of the
parents of all of those students have a
right to view that film so under this
statute if we are now filming incidents
where a child who has an IEP and has now
Ada
protections has had an outburst but
there are other students involved in the
Outburst are we potentially impacting
the privacy of that student who had the
Outburst by making these records now
available to all the other parents of
students who don't have the right to
know that that child has an IAP so thank
you representative Raymond it's also a
very good question uh and there's a lot
of gray areas in in this but that's why
we have a giant list of privacy
Protections in 126 it's all goes all the
way down to
well at least like V let mean in the in
the alphabet uh so there's a a host of
those so I I I don't think any of us
could honestly say for certain that a
background student walking down the hall
or you know that they encounter in
passing might
be um
videotaped they also might videotaped by
the existing hallway or exterior cameras
um I would say it wouldn't be
unreasonable to exclude the provision of
the audio video material to the parent
of Guardian of a student who was not
really subject of it who just you know
is an extra in the movie if you will
right just in in passing I'm not sure
how you do that I think we have a lot of
privacy Protections in 126 now it's all
about that uh or I could be seeing
actually 189 uh 189 sorry it's
18968 so follow follow up if I might
follow up yes thank you Mr chairman so
I'm envisioning CU right now we do have
surveillance in I'm from naswa U we have
surveillance quite a bit at a extreme
cost to the taxpayer of for the common
areas of the building but not
necessarily in classrooms so I'm
envisioning a situation where a child
has a behavioral event in a classroom
they you know uh flip over their desk
they throw some shoes multiple students
are impacted be by this because they are
in the vicinity of this child and as a
parent of the child who has been
impacted by the child who H who's having
the Outburst Behavior do I have a right
to view the video of what happened I I
think you probably do if your child was
materially impacted like injured enough
you know bruised injured even
psychologically damaged I think that
that would only be fair but I can tell
you this I'm glad you mentioned you were
from naswa NASA broads Elementary School
is number two on the list right 169
times and they implemented audiovisual
surveillance guess what happened to the
use of
restraints well I'll answer my own
question it went down right but our
audio video is in the seclusion it's not
in the class rooms because we're we're
managing the privacy and just to mention
Broad Street Elementary has a um a
special needs program for children who
would otherwise be placed out of
District so we actually children from
all over the city and from other
districts into that school to provide
special services so that they don't get
put out of district and in our case
typically out of state so yeah in In
fairness it's higher on the list because
you have a higher percentage that that
is true uh the most interesting point in
my opinion on Broad Street Elementary
School is that when they started using
audiovisual monitoring the numbers went
down a and the the friction right it's
to me it's the the the communication and
the friction between parents and
Educators is just can really be awful
and and awful in with kids with IEPs
right we know like that's that's often
where the source of trouble is and if
you can just say listen you know your
child threw two chairs through a window
and I know we wrote that down but let me
show it to you right I think I think the
discussion ends there and that's I think
helpful for everyone get back to let
Educators get back to educating and
anyway it's not I don't think there's
any perfect solution I think this is an
improvement thank you for your time
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and taking our questions so I think that
um that representative Raymond has has
covered the area that we're worried
about with uh privacy protections but
also just in going over the wording of
this bill and maybe some other hiccups
here one of the things it says um under
section two but it says that
the on contacting the parents that you
would contact the parents prior to the
use of this I'm I'm just wondering that
particular complication it's almost like
if there's an outburst we have to then
okay stop we'll go you know see if we
can get a hold of parents and tell them
we have to do that that that just seems
I don't know misplaced it seems like it
shouldn't be in there because I'm not
sure who would have time to do that
prior to the use of and if it would stop
any kind of intervention thinking that
they should maybe try to get a hold of
the parents to see if they can cord
before that you're thank you
representative Greg you're right that
would be ridiculous if it didn't say in
the same sentence just prior to that
unless prohibited by Court shall make
reasonable efforts to verbally notify so
that's the guardrail there
okay representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm wondering
um
what um what is your idea of um
including students without ni AP because
it could be a oneoff incident where
somebody is restrained um maybe they the
parents choose not to have an i AP but
they have behavioral uh issues and um
this is not addressed in your bill so
what would be the protection for that
particular student student thank you
representative Nelson for that question
it's an excellent point you're right
it's not included in there um this was
baby steps in a first first step follow
on to the restraint seclusion bills from
last year um I I like the idea I hope
that it doesn't happen to I'm told and I
my understanding from research is that
it doesn't happen nearly as often for
students without an IEP um sometimes on
the road to an IEP that's that those
things could happen so I I like the idea
um and if the child the non child we in
a seclusion room I think it's even more
more important uh since you know it's
almost there's less history in terms of
this it's even less predictable what's
going to happen so so the the bill
doesn't specifically address non-ip
child thank you representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson thank
you for being here and take my question
um in special education I um was an
emotional behavioral specialist for 12
years in the middle school and the most
important aspect in I felt in my job was
always protect the Dignity of the child
um and I will admit that um way back in
the years we've had to do restraining of
children um in order to keep them from
hurting themselves typically um if a
child got upset in a classroom we
emptied the classroom and then we let
the child stay there till they cool down
um but my question and what really
perked up my ears was your difficulty in
getting the data and I'm just curious
because I know that with my students
every time there was an out of school
placement I had to file that with in the
state of New Hampshire as part of the
IEP data collection um do they collect
when a child is taken out of a classroom
like most of my children that teachers
would call me and they could come to my
class to cool down do their work or
whatever but um I never had to report
every time they were taken removed from
their um environment from that
environment and I didn't have to report
if they had to um stay with me for a
certain amount of time or for how long
that time was is there anything now
that's requiring that data to be
collected and is that if not is it
something that should be put in here
where we're paying a little more um
closer attention to how often is the
child removed from their general
education um environment so thank you
representative ball for that question If
by removed you mean restrained we do
have a standardized as of last year
standardized form um that that the
districts have implemented our districts
implemented it the doe sent it out the
doe sent out specifically a technical
bulletin with the form attached uh after
the legislation was was passed um and I
will also say this I'm going to give you
kind of a half answer because there are
a number of experts behind me who know
every form the doe publishes and I do
not um but I do know that one because I
saw the technical bulletin and I've seen
it implemented in our own District
follow up please follow up so perhaps
because I have been out of the school
district and so that's why I'm asking
this question so now if I was in I had
my own classroom um where children can
come had chairs it was kind of a cool
down place it was not locked I stayed in
it all the time are you saying now if
that child was in the classroom and said
to their teacher I'm I'm going to lose
it that the teacher would send them to
my room that that would now be be
considered restraint rather than an
alternative placement um well the
definition of restraint is is in statute
so if that fits it which I don't have it
in front of me here and I'm not sure it
does um if that fits it then yes um I'll
clarify a little bit on the form so
there was a technical advisory that said
exactly what had to be in the form and a
sample form it is up to the district to
specifically as I understand it and I
could be corrected by an expert behind
me uh it's up to the district to adopt
their specific form the districts that I
spoke to after they received the
technical advisory literally cut and
paste out of the document and put the
words into their own form on their
letterhead that doesn't mean that
happened in every uh in every school
district but I'm sure there's plentiful
data on the implementation of the
standardized restraint form and every
other form the doe requires uh in the
folks behind me so I'll defer to them on
that
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank
you uh I'm trying to get a handle on
things here um you said you did some
research and it looks like you got a lot
of numbers on this what about damage to
the child how much damage is being done
by doing restraints I guess that's where
I'm
at thank you representative Bickford
good to see you um nice uh that that's a
a really nice point and a good question
um I would love for there to be um more
statistics on those forms and and to
answer some questions like those um the
answer is I don't know out of the 1,400
or so cases that were brought to us uh
and that was 2122 by the way the 20 2122
the most recent available data from doe
um I do think that the doe tabulates
some of that um we didn't disc discuss
it specifically in terms of damage like
how many students in those are a unique
students which is a very valid question
um excuse me and how many students were
injured injured enough to be transported
to a hospital or needed medical contest
I don't know uh the breakdown what I
will revert back to is 1,434 cases of
restraints in our schools are far too
many and whatever we can do to reduce
that and ease the minds of those parents
and guardians of those kids as to what
happened the better and I I'm hoping
this committee will find a way to do
that and I'm happy to work on you know
the language if if uh the experts here
followup question followup um what age
group is you are you looking at on this
I I assume the high school would not be
included with it I I I believe it was
and yeah I believe that's all all
students all 168,000 is
students oh one followup yes yeah well I
just thought the cro come in in place
there uh when there's acting up in a
high school even middle schools the you
mean if they're over 18 or no even even
juveniles you know the uh the school uh
resource officer which is a policeman
correct they're they're often on that
team if there's a resource officer in in
the school I assure you yeah that that
trained resource officer is one of the
five you know ideally five Personnel
that are part of that trained process
they most certainly are but not every as
you as everyone here already knows
school resource officers there aren't
enough of them and they're not at every
school and they're not always there at
the right time okay thank you
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um hi uh I'm a nurse I but I
don't really I don't work with children
I'm not in Pediatrics so I'm under the
impression so correct me if I'm wrong
that you know based on my experience
with like having to restrain dementia
patients and things
um any type of restraint has a risk for
harm and that's that's why we even in
the hospitals we try to minimize using
it and use any type of measure that we
can prior to restraints and get them out
of restraints as soon as possible um so
maybe you could let me know but I would
I would imagine that the situation be
similar so thank you representative
Gibbs for the question it's a great
question and you're you're certainly
speaking my language when it comes to
the healthcare setting which I'm more
knowledgeable about for
restraints um it is most certainly the
case of Last Resort um I do question
with the numbers as they are is it
really but I learned in research that
restraint I think I mentioned it for
early on in this testimony restraint can
be leading a child down the hallway
where the child wants to go down hallway
X and you lead them down hallway y now
they've been moved somewhere against
their will could qualify in the
definition of restraint I'm told uh and
I'm not a you know education law
attorney but those were the examples you
know one person on either side sort of
gently taking them by the arm it's not
the type of violent restraint four point
soft restraints hard restraints chemical
restraints that you and I may be
accustomed to in healthcare it's far far
from that and I think usually it is far
from that right that that's my
impression yeah um follow up follow up
uh I would not I I am surprised to learn
that leading someone down a hall would
be considered or restraint because in
the elderly the geriatric po uh
population that's not considered a
restraint as long as they can move
freely and so if you're just guiding
them because you know if someone's using
a walker they they could run into a wall
or something you're you you guide them
so that they don't collide with foreign
objects things like that we don't
consider that a restraint in the
hospital what we consider a restraint is
any any method that where they can't
freely move and sometimes that is from
my experience sometimes that is things
that you would have to think outside the
box for like I've seen um lnas use move
to a
question use trash cans underneath like
a recliner to elevate their legs but
then they can't put their leg their legs
down clever so wouldn't you believe
wouldn't you believe that that would be
a
thank you for the question so so in I
don't think that we encounter that in
the context of of an educational
institution I don't think that
particular type um so I think you bring
up a very fair and valid point that is
there a case of not over reporting but
reporting you know the administrators
and Educators would rather fill out the
form and report it for as much
transparency as possible um than not so
they error on the side of over reporting
if I could I don't know if that's really
the right term I don't want to
mischaracterize it um and I mean I what
led me to that thinking was talking with
our own District when they said well
we've got 49 cases so far I said what do
you mean it's like we're a month in and
that was the answer they said that you
know we report everything we write down
everything and I'm not sure the standard
is the same across every every school um
again I will the first sum of that
please bring that up again with the
experts behind me who work across many
schools good pair of professionals work
with clients so there's a lot of
different stories and and I don't know
what they all what they all will be so
um but I know some of them so I think
you'll get some good information from
them seeing no further questions thank
you so much for your testimony and
introducing your bill the chair
n
good morning Mr chair committee members
uh representative migu was um introduced
the bill and so I can just say ditto I'm
a
co-sponsor um Moren Tracy is a child
advocate and she invited all of the
marac state reps to meet with some of
the parents of special needs children
and hear hear their
stories and there a lot of those par
some of those parents are here today to
testify and you're going to hear um
father of one little boy who's
non-verbal came home injured more than
once and he couldn't tell his daddy what
happened because he he can't talk and
nobody at the school would would tell
him what happened tell the father what
happened and that's just one story
there's many more um so I really don't
need to answer any questions because
you've already grilled um representative
MCU so I'll end my test there we prefer
to call it interrogation but thank you
thank you thank you representative chair
recognizes uh Marine
Tracy and we're going to ask that people
keep your testimony to three or four
minutes because we got a stack of pink
cards if you have written testimony
please hand it to representative
you on you're on thank you chairman and
thank you everyone for listening to our
bill today I appreciate your attention
to this um I am a mom of four adult
children one is 27 who experienced
emotional behavioral disabilities in
school um that led me down a path of
teaching I have taught preschool special
ed regular Ed um middle school high
school and at the college level I've
also worked in many districts as a um
PBIS coordinator where I built systems
for schools such as lonier for the whole
District where I worked on building in
proactive systems to reduce um to reduce
restraint and seclusion as well as
Behavior the reason why I come to you
today is because um since covid I have
seen an increase in the amount of
families reaching out with children who
have injuries in
school where restraints and I I gave a
big pamphlet to you I'm not going to go
through it the whole thing but there's
many of the questions that you have
already asked um are answered in this
and feel free to contact me after if you
have any more questions um
however kids are not being restrained in
places like the lunchroom in the
classroom in the hallway for the most
part kids who are being restrained are
being restrained in segregated
classrooms where there is already a um a
a place for them to go in some used to
close the doors some now put up barriers
but it's a place to make a child go in
um if you see on the next page right
here uh I hope you have more you said on
your card you had 15 copies we only got
seven oh so if there's any more uh you
got yours okay we ran out I see I
apologize you have them we're too short
but okay I did give them to the audience
I'll I'll make sure to get them emailed
them to us I did email them to you as
well okay thank you that doesn't count
towards your three minutes
welcome these rooms are in a lot of our
elementary schools somebody asked the
question on what about high school at
the middle and high school you don't
typically see students restrained you
see people use different techniques to
re to reduce the behavior Elementary
School is where the most restraints and
seclusion happens and the most is
between the ages of 7 and 10 years old
where they are put into a room if you
can imagine if you were put into a room
like this you may start to fight and
then you may end up being restrained
because you didn't want to go into this
room most kids have um I'm going to skip
forward most students have um
disabilities 80% of students that are
restrained and secluded in schools uh
have disabilities there was a question
about what about if a student doesn't
have enough IEP and they do have a
behavior problem you could also look to
a 504 and make it an accommodation for
that um my biggest concern is monitoring
over oversight for children lots and
lots of families come to me and they are
in tears they have reached out
everywhere I have experienced this I now
have a three-year-old grandson who has a
speech delay who got on the bus and we
don't know what's happening there right
right there are cameras everywhere in
our in our society absolutely everywhere
kids come home bruised they come home
with rug Burns they come home with
concussions they come home with um notes
saying that they spent 2 hours in a
seclusion room and nobody knows what
happens half a minute as far as
documentation documentation is very very
difficult um because I can tell you even
the numbers that are there are not the
correct numbers my goal is that children
who don't have a voice have an extra set
of eyes which would be a camera to um to
actually help the parents and the staff
see what is need to be done thank you
very much would you take questions will
if there are any
questions representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson um as
you've mentioned you saw the thank you
for taking my question I'm sorry thank
you um you mentioned that you saw a lot
of these things in the school and we've
heard others say that some of the school
districts are now creating their own
programs within a school in order not to
outplay the children do you do you agree
or disagree with um keeping the children
in a public school as opposed to putting
them into a private outter school
placement for the children who are
really constantly being needing to be
going into
as someone who is 4 fo8 and has worked
with the most difficult behavioral
students including High School in the
state I never been hit kicked bit spit
at it is about technique and training as
somebody who taught at the University
level we do not teach that we do not
teach how to escalate we maybe we do it
once a year maybe it's like CPR we we
not we don't become experts in CPR right
I do think there's a there's so many
things we could do there could be
training training there could be um
systems there needs to be support there
there's so much we could do but in my
eyes right now I don't want anybody else
coming home hurt and I don't want to get
another phone call from another parent
saying this happened to my kid and I
don't know what happened
representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you so much for taking my question so
we've already uh acknowledged that there
are video cameras just about every
and I think uh representative Molton uh
mentioning her experience as a nurse
that you know when there is restraint um
there is occasionally harm that happens
and I'm not looking to minimize at all
because it is serious but is there an
implication that educational
professionals are abusing children
that's really the Crux of it I would say
that um staff go into their own fight or
flight mode because they have typically
who do we have working with our most
challenging students our paraeducators
who have not been taught on how to
deescalate and that's where the kind of
the problem comes from in Canada they
have the special education teachers
working with the kids and the par
Educators doing the paperwork we have
that opposite here in our country any
further
questions representative
long uh thank you Mr chairman uh and
thank you for taking my questions um so
so the uh have you been able to observe
video of these seclusion rooms I I have
been in seclusion rooms I have witnessed
restraints uh I've been in education for
25 years I've been at a consultant with
UNH for8 where I worked in lots of um
Elementary to high school so I have seen
I have witnessed it a lot okay follow
off
so so no you haven't seen the videos I'm
wondering if these videos
help I wonder if these videos Sor I
misunderstood your question or or uh
would uh deescalation training for par
professionals be more effective that's a
great question um I think automatically
when we are on camera we automatically
change our behavior um I just actually
had a case that went through due process
which we were lucky to have uh it
happened in a vesu the the student had
had had his whole day was spent there um
and we were able there was a report that
was written that looked like this child
should be locked up in conquered State
Prison it was so badly written and about
the child's Behavior we happened to find
a video on it and it did not match at
all what happened so I think
automatically we change our behavior
when we know we're being filmed that's
why restraints and seclusions are not
happening in classrooms where kids can
go home and say what happened that's why
they're happening in these rooms okay
thank you thank you representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
again for taking another question I'm
just curious because you made the um
statement about um it typically is a
parah that is out in the classrooms with
these children um when I did that as a
teacher my pars all had their cell
phones with me and I had my cell phone
with me so because I was actually
teaching in a classroom at the same time
um but they would we had a code you know
a green yellow red so that they could
tell me when I would check up and I did
check up on all my students that were
out in the janed classroom and they
could say no he's in greened sometimes
he'd say he's in yellow and I'd be like
let me know keep me and they might say
he's in yellow but you need to come so I
would be there before he hit the red was
there any kind of a system in the
schools that you worked with any kind of
direct communication so that the special
educator who is trained and that is
their area of expertise that you had an
immediate call to get me out of my
classroom and into your classroom um
that's an excellent question it makes me
think of two things one is first um
contacting the parent because I can tell
you I've watched it everybody is
contacted when it when a student of
known um escalation the principal's
contacted the secretary's contacted
everybody's everybody comes in right but
we don't want to get to that point and
what I think you're saying is an
excellent strategy of PBIS functional
Behavior assessments which is in the law
um what I am finding is that you know
after 10 days of of being in in
suspension or out of out of the typical
classroom um you're supposed to do a
functional Behavior assessment to
decrease that behavior that is not
happening and people are not
understanding what a functional Behavior
assessment is that's not being taught at
the at the um at the at the University
level as well follow up would you
believe that the majority of schools in
New Hampshire do not even know that
people that are certified as an
emotional behavioral specialist they
don't even realize that we are the
people who are supposed to be doing the
functional behavioral analysis I do
thank
you thank you for thank you for your
testimony thank
you sorry representative McMahon Mr Hand
I'm sorry sir thank you Mr
chairman Miss Tracy I assume you've read
the bill yes I have and specific uh to
where the existing Bill we're looking at
um on line five where it's stating uh um
visually and auditorily recorded if such
method is in the
IEP at at this point where the existing
law is apply uh by reading the existing
law does it apply to all as opposed to
in this case where is would this be
whether an IEP would preclude the use of
uh camera and auditory
monitoring in including no precluding
why yeah the point is why is it saying
if when it implies it was already in
place by existing
law I just see what the guidance I'm I'm
going to let the prime sponsor address
that come on up to the
microphone
that's a great question a a little bit
technical but um but a great question so
the idea is that since you can already
request
it in in in the IP and that's Def and
that ability nothing shall preclude is
in
189 the thinking was how do we draft
this as enabling legislation so so I see
parent with a child with an IEP gets a
report maybe two of restraint or
seclusion and for whatever reason they
don't feel like they got quite enough
information the report was not filled
out well they didn't get it at all it
took a month and a half to get it or for
whatever reason they didn't get enough
and I'm not saying those things
necessarily happen because I I'm not I
don't think they do I think the
Educators take the practice very
seriously because it is but then they
might say could you could you please put
them in the room with the camera can you
put a camera in there can somebody
whoever is in charge of the one-on-one
in in seclusion right then they can
request that as part of the IEP right
that that's how I think this will work
right you could a parent could with
great forethought and I think somebody
else pointed out and I think the office
of the child advocate is going to point
it out in their written testimony if
they haven't already um that that kids
without
iips uh it's a little more difficult to
implement the whole audio video thing
and parents who didn't think of it in
advance so it may be reactionary right
but I think we also ought to give the
schools a chance to do it right and you
know report
properly and it's it it's for the case
where there's unanswered questions and
this is an attempt to answer those
questions that does that does that make
sense that answer your question as far
as how it's structured and what's
statute and the
language um follow up thank you Mr
chairman um I'll I'll stipulate to your
knowledge and the homework that you've
already done mean it's it's a debating
point of application versus reality when
you're on the battlefield here isn't it
always yes and um my my point here is oh
not my point my question to to both of
you is can we have a homogeneous
language that applies to all then once
you cross the threshold of the school
that your the rules apply to all and and
to ensure that compliance to the intent
here and not a subjective application
based on opinion whether an
I uh or not an IEP will apply for
audiovisual um uh Records for those who
are in the uh having a problem and are
in a secluded room or a protected area
you could I think this bill is 3/4 of a
loaf and that's a loaf and a half uh we
go with just a full loaf then yeah yeah
so there you you definitely could and I
think that there's some support for that
I'm not sure there's broad political
will for that particular practice
without trying it this way first um
certainly an interesting concept curious
what some of the other folks had to
think about it representative I see no
language that doesn't mean it's not here
it just means I don't see it um that
would say to the schools now you have to
let the parents of the children with
IEPs know about this provision
how would they find out yeah another
great point and that's actually in the
written testimony from the office of the
child advocate um yeah it's on line 23
I'm reading it yeah oh their testimony
oh yeah great yeah and it's another very
valid point um but I so no I don't have
an answer for you okay I really don't I
mean I don't I think that the interested
parties such as those who brought this
to our attention I have a feeling that
word spreads fairly fast amongst that
community
thank you like it did want the technical
bulletin I got it before it even made it
to the school
so anyone yes representative
bford uh thank you Mr chairman I have a
question for
Morin uh on your handout Morin on page
12 you say increase in injuries there
has been an increase in injuries of
children who are restrained and secluded
there has been an increase in injuries
to children who are placed in special
education rooms and on page 30 you say
we need to stop kids from being hurt
today do you have any where did that
data come from I know you didn't note
the data on that
page I I can absolutely get you the
information on that data um so part of
it is from one is from my own experience
because I have been advocating for so
long and the injuries have been getting
hurt but I also researched it in um
through the
um and I'm forgetting the name um first
of all the worldwide health organization
as well as um the Department of
Education Federal special education oh
Federal Yes Federal yes and I can I can
get you that information one other
follow up thank you Mr chairman thank
you um are there more IEP students now
than there used to be is has I know uh
student population is going down but I'm
wondering if the IEP students have been
going up and that would of course skew
the statistic
someone if we're not keeping that in in
percent wise uh I'm not sure of that
information but I can I can get that for
you okay that would be good yeah thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you very much chair recognizes Mr Ryan
day and you have handouts Ryan day if
you would hand them out only this way so
way yeah yeah that's fine
uh you said you had 15 copies of written
testimony so thank you and uh once again
three minutes for your testimony please
thank you Mr chairman and the house of
family and law
committee my name is Ryan Day I live in
Manchester with my wife and two children
1269 I have a seven-year-old son named
Phillip he's diagnosed with autism
spectrum
disorder um Philip has communication
issues uh he'd be considered
non-verbal uh he does not have
behavioral issues he's not a violent kid
um he's very sweet he wants to please
love spending time with family spend a
lot of time at the playground we go on a
lot of
hiking um in Manchester when we started
school they had a preschool program that
was
fantastic uh kindergarten came around
and we requested extra support for
philli in the general education
classroom we were told he would get a
paah shared with one other student we
found out the per was there to support
the whole
class when discussing his IEP for first
grade we requested a one-on-one in
general education we were told
Manchester doesn't do Ono ones and we
made to feel like we didn't have a
choice but to put him in a
self-contained classroom in order for
him to get the support he
needs so first grade Phillip um went to
Highland and Philip started coming home
with face injuries including bruises on
his face swelling fat
lip adult tooth knocked loose tooth cut
onto the inside lip swollen jaw that
lasted a couple of weeks
we were told that those injuries were
Tripp and
Falls we we don't believe it Philip's
not accident prone he's very active we
do a lot of hiking outdoor
stuff um we also he also started wetting
his pants in school and not at
home we brought this up multiple times
and we were told that he was just
regressing feeling desperate and
helpless I I decided to hire an advocate
to get Philip out of the school my
Advocate pulled the nurse's reports on
his injuries and the reports had
different accounts of what happened that
what we were being
told um that just didn't make sense
including falling off a
table we were able to pull Philip out of
Highland and get him back to his
neighborhood school for
for um second grade with a one to one
going through this awful experience
motivated me to share my story with my
local legislators last August you've got
one minute left sir one minute
left and also enroll in the UNH
leadership program to learn to become a
better advocate for my son a few weeks
ago I saw in the news that a therapist
that regularly worked with Philip at
Highland last year was caught on
camera and arrested for assaulting a
non-verbal 7-year-old boy with autism
what would you guys think about this if
you were in my
shoes I filed the police report I was
told by the detective that it would be
difficult to press any charges because
statement um this bill is important to
to me and my family because children
without a voice need to be protected we
need to restore safety and
accountability in our classrooms I think
this bill would be made stronger if we
expanded it to cover all all the
self-contained classrooms where our most
vulnerable children are thank you for
your testimony does anyone have any uh
day I see none thank you for your story
thank you for your
Caruso and once again three
minutes thank you
um so um the dad of a 11-year-old
non-verbal
child uh early on in his school career
he received several injuries um some of
those are going to
be uh for the rest of his life
um along with that uh we had lots of
issues um trying to
decipher stories and figure out what
happened uh took pictures filed
complaints did everything we were
supposed to do as parents to try and
remedy the
situation
um so
through covid uh going to remote
learning we learned a lot about his IEP
team
dysfunction I think it's one of the
things it's important to remember like
with
um special needs children it's the
implementation of the
programming sometimes that can
cause difficulties with with the child
not understanding different things like
that however as we talk about like de
escalating
um it's it's before they even escalate
so what's happening prior to that's the
problem as far as I see with with that
uh and as we talk about seclusion rooms
in the many different names of those
rooms so could be a break room sensory
room uh there's multiple different
levels of names for those types of
spaces um it's important I support the
bill uh accountability for the
schools and the people with these
children that are in areas especially
non-verbal children children my child
not being able to tell a story as a
slightly overprotective dad uh you know
that's what we do keep our kids safe um
no matter what so um going through all
those experiences he now is taught at
home he's being
homeschooled uh where he's safe and
happy now he's he has a he's a gentle
loving child so
um but during some of those injuries I I
requested film footage and and video
half a minute sir um and had very
difficult time getting that from the
school so I I think it's important for
uh video audio in these spaces with
non-verbal
children thank you Mr Caruso any
questions Vice chairman long thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you your
deescalation comment makes a lot of
sense uh when your child was in school
did he have an IEP he did and was video
allowed uh no I actually requested
several different things uh one was the
video footage I also uh on my own at my
own cost I would have supplied a person
to accompany him through his school day
that worked for me and not the school
district in order to keep him safe that
was denied so so there's different uh I
did everything I thought I could do to
keep him in school and with his
peers so okay thank thank you
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank you so your concern is
you want cameras in the
classroom it it doesn't sound like there
was a restrain issue here it's a
classroom issue or all allaround issue
maybe I should say yeah I mean just to
be clear like he had um there were rooms
that were called senty rooms called what
sensory rooms sensory okay yeah or and
break rooms and and different they have
different names but basically it's the
same idea removed from everybody uh he
would go in
there and there's no video and audio in
there to to tell us what happened so
okay thank you just in no space not
representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman Mr Cru who may ask what school
district your in uh he was in uh Shaker
Regional I'm I'm sorry he was in Shaker
Regional School sh Regional One followup
Mr chairman followup um relative to what
uh you've stated and uh in what you've
stated I believe is part of part of this
is to have video and audio available uh
this becomes a funding issue and within
that uh that being said would you
believe that we should be looking at a
requ a requirement with a funding uh
adjunct to ensure that this is complied
throughout our school districts in the
state of New Hampshire I I do uh you
know with with special needs children uh
the funding side is like the adult
problem that shouldn't be passed down to
the special needs kids in other words
you know sure changing them because of
the funding that's that's the adult
problem but I it should be included okay
one last followup follow up and Mr cruso
um just so I understand correctly you
said you had a difficult time asking for
video does that imply that video
existed uh well we tried to get video of
certain um injuries that happened other
words in the hallway and um you know it
was explained that that might have been
a blind spot in the camera there so it's
kind of
a you you know you're at a disadvantage
because you're on the outside of the
school uh so so you know once you once
the doors close you're you're kind of
taking whatever they tell you whether it
makes sense or not just one one more
Point Mr CH one more one more absolutely
uh regarding the pictures that we were
looking at then the description from the
authorities having jurisdiction stated
they were based on falls in the
[Music]
school oh like like the other gentlem
we're seeing what's taking place here I
wanted to tie to what you're talking
about
can you were there any in injuries with
your your children child and uh that
were seen coming home at all that that's
why you're asking for or or not asking
but saying we should have audio and
video there were many yes there were
many and was there any explanation as to
what caused those injuries uh not
exactly uh full explanation no okay
thank you sir representative
deimon thank you Mr Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
sir I do believe you when you say your
child is a a gentle little boy my
question to you sir is when you inquired
why your child was placed in seclusion
were you giving given any valid reasons
and if so why your child's issue was not
audio so I it's when you're not in the
school it's it's hard to understand what
what's happening uh so typically like uh
as it was said a sensory room would be
something where he would go there
to um you know after doing some school
workor and maybe go to the sentury room
as kind of like to just chill L I guess
um but that def you know according to
the injuries I saw I I I have a lot of
questions
but that's that's behind me now so I
mean thank you for bringing this forward
to us I appreciate that representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your testimony and taking my
call I'm very sorry what happened to
your son I'm um just trying to get a
full understanding of the problem and
issues here so if
um did you um receive
um
any
um information
documentation about your child's
injuries
restrained uh
you know I I don't know if we received a
whole lot of information in general
about injuries um you would think that
would be uh so when a child's injured in
school there's a protocol that goes into
action where everybody's informed
reports are sent home um that kind of
stuff uh didn't happen like unless we
asked for
information the nurses reports um so not
all injuries were exactly
recorded that way can I just have a
follow follow up and I'm sorry I'm
really not trying to grill you I'm just
trying to get down to the root of the of
the problem so I really appreciate you
um answering my questions um
so were you notified if at all um that
when I I don't know if I can answer that
exact ly because I'm not sure the
way thank you Mr Caruso for your
testimony thank you the chair calls
Wendy
fiser she's asking for three minutes you
got it oh I might take four well
no hi thank you all for your time today
my name is Wendy fiser um I have a now
11-year-old he was 10 at the time of the
incident and he is in the nashaa school
district uh my son went to Broad Street
Elementary School he was in a program um
called project achievement which is
basically um a program that's in a
segregated classroom with the idea of
hoping to mainstream the child he had
some um and still does social emotional
um issues and that is or challenges and
that is why he is was in this particular
uh program
program so I'll back up just a little
bit I was an active mom in the school
PTO president I don't say that to tout
myself but I was very much ingrained
with the culture of Broad Street school
so I felt very um I don't know if in the
no was the right uh way to say this but
I felt very comfortable in trusting the
process of how my son was being educated
and when they referred him into this
program again I trusted the process I
didn't fully understand the process and
you learn what you need to learn or
after the fact when something tragic
happens so back um I guess over the last
three years from 2020 to March 28th
2023 my son was placed um he was
restrained over 30 times and placed in
seclusion over
40 the last time that he was placed in
seclusion on March 28th
2023 he took his sweatshir shirt off he
was placed in seclusion for over an hour
he took his sweatshirt off he wanted out
of the room and he wrapped the
sweatshirt around his neck and attempted
to take his life while he was in that
room this is really
overwhelming
so okay I didn't want that to happen
today
so thank you for bearing with
me so on March 28th he attempted to take
seclusion Miss Raymond I would love to
talk with you after because there are a
bunch of Board of Education policies
that were
not taken into consideration or
completed or
time okay so
he um over that time he was restrained
secluded over the three years what I
learned after the fact so I can just get
to the end of my three minutes here is
that um I'm hearing a lot of talk this
is the benefit of going like third or
fourth um talking about physical damage
and what I'm not hearing any discussion
about is the mental damage that is
placed on the child that is consistently
in um restraint and seclusion I'm asking
for your support of this bu
because the first thing I did what would
be the first thing you would do as a
parent if your child harmed himself in
school while in
seclusion you would ask to see the
videotape you so I did and I was met
with we don't have videotape of that
room my son is in one of the most
intensive special need programs in the
NASA school district and there are not
cameras in the seclusion room
not that was a shock to me I had no idea
I knew that there were cameras in school
you can see them in the hallways I just
assumed as a mom that there were cameras
in this area they're not would you take
some questions from the uh committee yes
but before we do well you only have
about 20 seconds and I've already let
you go over so all right so someone
mentioned the Dignity of the child and
protecting the Dignity of the child
when a child is placed in seclusion in a
special ed classroom and he's regul
regulated to um this smaller room the
Dignity of the child is already
gone so you know what bring on the
cameras to hold on accountability to
those that are in this that are managing
this program in the
school do we have any questions for uh
Miss
fiser representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson and
thank you so much for your testimony and
I'm terribly sorry to hear what happened
to your son um I am the one who
mentioned the Dignity of the the student
and I absolutely agree with you
protecting the Dignity of the student
means treating that CH student as a
valued human being and protecting their
integrity and their feelings and all the
parts about them so I'm especially sorry
to hear all of these stories um
certainly never happened um in the
school that I was in thank goodness
um would you think that this bill could
be improved if there was some type of a
requirement given that the school
districts now the public school
districts in order to not outplay
children are creating these programs
within their school should there be a
requirement that in these very intensive
programs within the school that there be
video cameras in all areas yes thank
you any other questions represent
resentative long thank you uh Mr
chairman and thank you Miss Fischer uh I
certainly uh am aware of the mental
effect on a child that that's
unacceptable um so do you truly believe
that passage of this bill that you would
get the answers you
need when uh on audio and video inside a
seclusion room I mean it it it seems
that a lot of this is happening prior to
um but at the time they're in the
seclusion
room you know so so you know I just need
your assurance that you believe this
passage you would get your answers I'm
not sure of that that's kind of like
there's a lot of answers to that
question that you're asking so I guess
the short answer is yes in this
particular instance on March 28th I
would have the answers of what happened
it's a lot of he said she she said type
of dialogue that has been going on so in
this instance but what I will say is if
that we had cameras in seclusion rooms
monitoring the behavior of not only the
teacher and the child and I don't want
to use the word monitoring because what
I want to come out of this at the end is
more
training and the
staff there's nothing better than
playback video right when you're in the
Heat of the Moment you're not going to
remember what said what you did what the
child
did what is important is to have the
video is feedback footage doesn't
lie so if we can take this footage and
not only protect the teacher the child
and everybody involved with what's going
on in that particular moment at that
particular time if we can take that
footage and actually
train the folks that are leading these
highly intense ensive programs that
involve restraint and
seclusion then one not only are we
holding them accountable but two we can
process does that answer question
appreciate that it does thank you
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman so if I understand this
correctly um please correct me if I'm
wrong but the the overall um goal is for
Less restraints and if there was videos
on the staff interactions with the child
then we would have less restraint usage
overall is that your understanding um
that would be the goal yes so Moren has
already sort of touched upon that that
that's we want to reduce the amount of
time people are restrained and people do
behave differently when they know
they're on camera it's a fact
and for us yes it would be training it
would be training to help reduce that's
the back end of this story is we're all
focusing on the cameras in the room but
what's the what's the the next step is
to take that footage and be able to go
through that footage with the people
that are involved with what's going on
that day and train them properly we do
not have properly trained people I'm
going to speak specifically for NASA
that are running the project achievement
program we have moms off the
street that par Educators placed in a
classroom with highly intensive need
kiddos and it's not right and that is
when your son is in fight or flight the
entire time that they are in
school that par educator they're not
them representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and
I I my heart's broken for what you've
gone
through would you agree ma'am
that psychologically we are
made to immediately report how something
feels not how something actually
happened therefore video and audio are
Paramount to getting to the truth and
Crux of any situation that is a great
question
and in any of our situations for the
folks sitting behind me it's highly
emotional right we just want data so if
you put a video in front of me with
audio that's just data I can remove the
feelings from that and and manage the
data so yes thank you very much anyone
else uh can I just add one little thing
uh no I'm afraid you can't because we're
really way over time so thank you Miss
fer and to chair now recognizes Megan
paage who's asked for three minutes and
has some handouts if you can give the
handouts you say you have 11 copies yeah
I
don't and remember three minutes to make
your
presentation hello thank you very much
for allowing me to be here uh my name is
Megan pagee I live in Meredith New
Hampshire I have a daughter named Brooke
I adopted Brooke through New Hampshire
foster care
system she attends Interlake school
district and has for seven years my
daughter was born with a genetic
disorder that causes a number of
disabilities including but not limited
to epilepsy and autism she has required
an IEP and a one-on-one par educator
since she started school and she still
does last year while at interl
Elementary School the best way I can
describe what my daughter went through
is sheer
hell she
began having really bad behaviors and I
was being called all the time to come
and pick her up from school she's always
had her fair share of struggles but
never anything like this I didn't know
what was going on after I was approached
by the school to agree to a half a day
of school from my daughter I knew I
needed to do something and figure out
what exactly was going on I hired an
educational Advocate
Moren in the meantime my daughter was
also suspended and was not welcomed back
to the school unless I met with a
superintendent I knew this was wrong not
one person decides the fate of a child
there's an IEP team for a
reason with the help of my Advocate we
found out my daughter was restrained and
also put in a seclusion room more times
than I can count in addition there was
very little communication almost no
communication from the school about any
of this
this we also found out they were not
following her IEP and had changed her
routine she had been following for years
all without my knowledge her behaviors
were all starting to make sense there
are many things the school failed to do
but if cameras had been in the seclusion
room or or there while she was being
restrained I would know what actual
trauma my daughter
endured to this day I really don't know
what happened except what the school has
told me and clearly they haven't been
very forthright up until this point what
I do know is moving her out of this
environment and up to the Middle School
still in the same district has been
life-changing for her she is making
tremendous progress all I have done with
the help of my amazing Advocate is hold
the school
accountable cameras would be another way
to assist in holding the school
accountable and hopefully preventing any
more trauma on our children we send our
children to school in hopes they will
build relationships learn the skills
they need to succeed in life all while
having fun with their peers no one sends
their child to school expecting their
child to be
traumatized please consider supporting
this bill and help us parents hold the
school accountable for our most prized
possessions our children thank you thank
you Miss Paige any
questions for the witness representative
Nelson um thank you for coming here and
I'm very sorry for your experience my
daughter's name is broke too and so you
kind of sorry I'm wear my heart on my
sleeve um I'm if you could just please
um help me understand was when she was
in seclusion um was it being used as a
discipline you know I
I I've I saw the seclusion room um it
was basically a concrete
closet um the door was open um and
I don't know I don't know if it was
punishment
or well followup Please Mr chairman
followup thank you Mr chairman um so you
were not notified why she was put in a
the seclusion room she she was having
she had behaviors um she would get upset
um at different points
um and she has had her own struggles
throughout school but never anything
like this and I had no idea what was
going on and finding out that they had
changed everything about her school
day um required or they felt it required
her to be in seclusion thank you for
answering my question and just like I
said to the gentleman before you my
questions are not to give you a hard
time I'm just really trying to get a
full understanding of the situation so I
appreciate it
yep representative
long thank you Mr chairman and
uh thank you thank you for the adoption
um in the seclusion room uh was there an
adult with her that she trusted do you
know um yes when um when she was in
seclusion there were about five adults
standing in the doorway staring at her
waiting for her to calm
down that's what seclusion looked like
for follow follow up if I made so so the
door was open yep okay all right thank
you
y and thank you for coming I see no
further hands up thank you for your
testimony thank you and uh committee and
people who give testimony never
apologize in this committee for wearing
your motions on your sleeve it is the
nature of what we do
here the chair recognizes Mr Roger is it
Esley yes come on up and you ask for one
minute I'm going to force you to
three you're G you're going to what I'm
going to say your one and raise your two
okay um I'm a little different than all
the parents who Spoken Here my child is
30 and um what's astonishing about the T
Moren came to work with me because she's
working with my adult daughter and the
struggles she has in our
world um
what is astonishing about the testimony
here
is I feel like I know every story they
school including being sexually abused
and forced to do a police
interview when she operates at the level
of a first
grader she was forced to go up where the
police asked her questions when she came
out she said a sense she's never said to
us before I didn't do it I didn't do
these things the very idea that lying
she be lying was news to
her
so although I think this bill has to be
passed and somebody said baby steps
that's great the truth is our culture is
a seclusion room for people with
disabilities they're left behind and
ignored at every level and when they
come in contact with for example the
police department the police department
doesn't have a clue how to talk to my
daughter and find out what's true so
that I heard the thing of oh he couldn't
testify so we can't do anything so um I
I simply want to say boy I would have
loved it if there was video when we were
in a school which we were lied to so
many times it was
it was news to me that people could lie
at the level they were lying at so I I
as actually I'm a consultant schools
I've been to Broad Street school for
five years as a consultant working with
them using visual tools I think it's a
great school but I also
know
that what happens at one end of the hall
may not be what happens at the other end
of the
hall thank you any questions from Mr
Esley thank you sir s all right
yeah thank you so
Bowden you've asked for two minutes
stretch it a little would you have a
three minute rule here thank you
chairman Pearson um for the record my
name is Lisa Bodwin I am a Disability
Policy
professional uh and served for six years
on the state of
advisory committee on the education of
students with disabilities as their
chair um I don't have a story to share
with you my son who had KN he was not
secluded and restrained but I'm here as
a policy expert and I wanted to share a
few additional sort of fundamental ideas
including that
um teachers and other staff that schools
are well intentioned and trained and do
do an overall very good job however
structurally schools are hot beds of
unconscious bias against students with
disabilities that's why we have separate
educational system for them it's we call
it special education but it in fact is a
segregated educational system and that
that
inadvertently has a mindset of my my
students and those students um it leads
to ideas for instance this this
unconscious bias against students with
disabilities that there is a presumption
that the behavior that students have is
solely because of the
student right and we need we need to
bear in mind that behaviors are a form
of communication and if you're in a hot
bed of unconscious bias in a in a
building where you do not have a feeling
of
belonging I I would start Behaving Badly
too um I would also add that
um just because a student does not have
the ability to use words to communicate
does not mean that they are not
thinking i' like to use the metaphor
that we may not have the
um the Rosetta Stone on the mind of
student students who don't use words to
communicate but their noodles are filled
with thoughts ideas preferences desires
dreams and hopes even if we do not yet
have the technology to give the to to to
translate what might be going on in
their minds for those students who are
called quote unquote non-verbal that
fundamentally restraint and seclusion is
traumatizing for the student and that it
should be at the center of your minds
when you're thinking about this bill and
I give you another half minute
okay until we can fix the challenge of
segregated education for students with
disabilities we need to have and and
create places of belonging for them we
need to have measures that hold schools
accountable and we need to have measures
that protect students with disabilities
from the trauma that they are currently
experiencing we cannot fix the challenge
in our schools tomorrow but until we do
video cameras is one way to make sure
that everybody has the same information
about what's happening seclusion rooms
are fundamentally bad practice and they
need to stop any questions for Miss
Bodwin sing none thank you for your
testimony and the final person to come
before us today is Karen
Rosenberg from the disability rights
Hampshire thank you everyone I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center and um I have
to say I'm coming to you extremely
reluctantly in opposition to the spell I
think it needs work I think there is
we've a problem in this state we have a
problem where students are being
restrained and secluded in
unconscionable numbers at unconscionable
rates and video and audio recording
would be tremendously helpful I mean it
is a really good tool to be able to see
the reality of what's happening I've
been involved in investigating
complaints of harm that has occurred
during restraints and seclusion
including at the cunu center
and I'll tell you that in the most
recent report we did which was pretty
long time ago at this point it was the
video recording even without sound that
was really helpful in being able to
determine what actually occurred um and
to and to compare that with the report
that was required under our state law
was very very powerful this law this
bill does not require recording it
doesn't require anything that's already
not that's already
not required in our current law Federal
Law requires schools to implement
individualized education programs or
IEPs that is the law so if an IEP
provides for audio visual recording then
that the school district must Implement
that provision so this does not add to
what's currently required the challenge
for parents is that they are one member
or the of the IEP team and when push
comes to shove
it is the school team members who will
decide what the IEP team's decision is
and if the parent doesn't agree with
that then the parent May appeal that
decision through a procedure called due
process so the fact that a parent
requests this does not guarantee that
they will get a recording it could be
something that they might get a lot of
push back on another concern that our
office has is that it's really important
to keep in mind that that rest straint
and seclusion these are emergency
interventions they should only be used
when there is an imminent risk of
substantial bodily harm in the case of
restraint the idea that you could ever
notify a parent before you restrain a
kid it is is impossible because if you
could do that then there is no emergency
and there is no need for restraint and
we're very concerned that we don't we
don't want to take any chance that the
standard for restraint or seclusion this
emergency standard getss watered down
one minute to go I think another area
where our current law may be lacking or
at least enforcement is lacking is in
oversight currently our restraint and
seclusion law does require um school
districts and and Facilities to document
and provide a lot of documentation about
what happens what leads to restraint all
all kinds of things about the Restraint
of seclusion and it's up to the
Department of Education and DHHS to riew
those records and oversee what's going
on and oversee compliance yet they do
nothing other than send a report to you
all with the numbers of restraints the
numbers of seclusions the schools that
they occurred and whether there's
complaints pending so this might be
another area to take on so like I said
there's a big problem here I just am not
confident that this law really
adequately addresses it thank you Miss
Rosenberg representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman thank you
so much for your testimony I just wanted
to share with all of you who testified
today that as a child I was often placed
in a seclusion room so I hear your
testimony and thank you so much for your
heartfelt uh words today thank
you representative long thank you Mr
chairman uh so Mr Rosenberg uh are you
also we already we ALS we heard
testimony that it's I believe it was 80%
our special needs and I APS are you of
that same opinion yeah I believe that
that it's disproportionately students
with disabilities who are subjected to
these practices okay thank
you thank you for your
testimony
what chair recognizes representative
Bickford sorry sir thank you Mr chairman
um so do you have a better
plan well I think there were some
suggestions made by members of this
committee such as requiring audiovisual
tap in in seclusion rooms or in
contained classrooms I mean those are
the places where children with the
highest behavioral needs tend to be
segregated I agree with Lisa Bodwin that
this is wrong we shouldn't be
segregating children with disabilities
but right now they students with
disabilities and students with extreme
behavioral challenges are getting
managed in segregated classrooms and in
seclusion rooms and those would be
appropriate places to have video cameras
installed and not having be a question
that parents have to fight through the
whole IEP team
process okay thank
you this concludes the hearing on House
Bill
1269 uh it should be of interest to most
of you that the schedule for this
committee for the 20th is already set
and in the schedule on the 27th we have
vacation and so this bill with many
others heard today will be exact on
March 5th so if you have some
suggestions to the prime sponsor the
committee or others testifying you've
got about three weeks to work up
do no we we've concluded the hearing and
I gave you some other time at the table
which I usually do but not supposed to
1027 we will open at
115 and address 1
1027 and also 1659 and then we will go
session
for
then
uh for those of you who are
here um I am going to open a hearing on
a different bill because it's left over
from this morning I'm going to open it
up and then recess it and close it so
don't think that either you've been
forgotten or what whatever okay just a
do I open the hearing on House Bill
1027 and the um chair calls on the clerk
representative patrino to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
open the uh hearing on House Bill 1027
relative to allowing child support to
include the period of pregnancy thank
you representative and now I put this
bill this hearing into recess and I
close the hearing on house bille 1027 we
will get to it later so that we can move
to the bill that was advertised for
115 I open a hearing on House Bill
[Music]
1659 and the chair recognizes the prime
post she's
she's not here representative long would
line Thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
introduce hos B 1159 well try 1659 1659
I like is that the one that is relative
to interference with child cust and
Sharon sharing parenting yes yes thank
rehearsed chair recognizes uh Meredith
Costello
and Karen Hopkins gets to come up
too and you are first faced with the
hardest part of testifying
here
which
is hit buttons until something goes red
you did it now this is going to be easy
tell us about the
bill um it is about parental rights um
ensuring accountability for um parenting
time um Financial reimbursement for any
legal fees um if the person is found um
keeping the children when they shouldn't
be um is that a good summary for it and
why do you think this is a good idea
yeah well I'd love to read my testimony
and tell you my experience well you can
it um okay well um my ex-husband um was
very abusive during my marriage uh I
have two daughters um Ma and Quinn who
have not been home um Ma has not been
home in 458 days and Quinn has not been
home in 333 days I'm sorry
um they have had no meaningful time or
connection with um their entire maternal
side of their family so that would be
their little brother my parents um their
stepfather Aunts Uncles cousins
everybody um I'm here with my cousin
Karen Hopkins um who has two children
that she has not seen since March of
2020 her entire maternal side of her
family has also had no contact thank you
by the way what while you're using that
we have a rule here no one is ever to
apologize for showing emotion thank you
this is what we do wasn't expecting
it um so I was trying to summarize um my
husband ex-husband has continued to be
abusive we've been divorced for going on
eight years um but he uses time to
communicate about children as um a means
of harassment to denigrate me um it's
been really cruel over the years I have
done a quantitative analysis and a
qualitative analysis of those messages
for the courts to show the sheer amount
of harassment and types of messages that
come in um that has been pretty futi
futile to get any kind of relief from
any of that um this most recent attempt
to uh take my children and my parenting
time which I it is important to state
that uh no judge has said that they
should not return my children to me in
this year and a half the court system
the family court system is a really
ineffective terrible place to
be um as a summary some of the things
that I had in here to tell you is in the
past 24 months I have still no
resolution about this
situation because of delays G's not
getting things in in time having
different judges who contradict each
other getting court dates cancelled and
then when you when that happens in the
family court system you get put to the
bottom of the pile so if something gets
canceled you get put down 3 to four
months out so months and months and
months are going by without time with my
children because of some severe systemic
failures this all trickles down to the
emotional health obviously of myself my
children my entire family um and also
the Financial Health I have uh taken a
second mortgage on my home um I have
gone through savings um that's just in
the past 24 months so that is not what
I've spent in the course of in the past
9 years lawyers are very very expensive
and when you have a court system that
cannot be effective and expeditious in
getting decisions made for you that cost
your constituents a ton of money I asked
Karen if she could please summarize what
she spent over her time fighting for her
children she told me that she has spent
60 she spent
$60,000 she borrowed that money from her
parents' retirement and she is working
to pay that off right now
um so severe Financial consequences when
you have such severe systemic failures
happening in your court system how do
you believe that this bill will address
that because that's what we're here for
is this bill yeah so I mean of course I
can see that there's the accountability
of not returning your child which could
be possibly $500 a day right every day
it said on there that you don't return
your child there needs to be some kind
of way to um hold people accountable
because he's been able to hold on to
them without any consequence at this
point so I think that that is vitally
important I say to you that like I think
part of the bill also talks about
getting Financial reimbursement for your
legal fees which I think is wonderful um
I will say you know I have a master's
degree I am I am midcareer and I have
still struggled to pay for and navigate
the family court systems so you can
reimburse somebody but not everyone has
the
$7,500 retainer that that lawyer is
asking for to even get things started so
I'm glad to see that there would be some
reimbursement on the back end fear for
the people that have less education or
in a lower sces bracket than myself that
are trying to navigate this system
because I struggle with it in my
position and do you wish uh cousin to
speak as well um no she she's been
pretty much doing all of that for me she
get a lot in there and time allotted
thank you any questions for and this is
Meredith Costello any
questions
anybody I can tell you one thing that
the legislature has done and that is we
have in the budget that is now in effect
we've got more Circuit Court judges some
of which will go to Family Court and
we've only just begun the study that
looked at the needs indicated at least
21 judges on the Circuit Court
additionally uh this time we've got
seven or actually six in the circuit and
one on Superior and more are coming and
that is one of the reasons for delay is
not enough judges so that's being worked
on and uh other things are in the back
of the minds of some of us as well but
we are cognizant of this okay
any
questions seeing
none seeing none seeing
one that is going to be yeah that's well
that's overd doing too much here that's
perfect okay thank you Mr now I remember
your name is representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
Costello for coming to speak to us um so
I noticed that you're in support of um
the consequences for failing to comply
with parenting orders I'm curious about
how how um or how you feel about um the
bill at the beginning of the bill it
talks about um accept is otherwise
precluded by state or
law um if any individual professional
public or private denies or fails access
to Medical Dental Etc records to either
parent should be held responsible I'm
I'm curious about whether that part
would impact your family situation like
um if there are any barriers in your
parenting plan to either one parent
access accessing those records and if
that would be um dangerous to have
someone access it if they're not allowed
to uh there's nothing in our parenting
plan that says either of us can't access
everything for our children so for me
that isn't something that has been an
issue thank
you representative Panic thank youman
for letting me uh ask this question and
thank you for um coming in today
I have a question on um on the amendment
that was brought in on line
19 can't discuss an amendment sorry at
this point no I won't I can bring it to
second see okay got
it on on uh page one on the bill line
number
29 uh item C it says
sh thank you and thank your
cousin thank you I have my full
testimony can I pass that out you indeed
May okay thank you very much for your
time and you can give it to
representative Bickford and he's got a
great record of passing things around
things
wow
is that multiple copies of the testimony
everyone's getting a binder of the
testimony wow I mean nobody's been this
you we do things like that here but we
don't do Girl Scout cookies this year
right
[Music]
that's out
back wow this is really impressive
I wonder what I was going to do tonight
yeah get some homework here look at this
thank
you the chair recognizes The Honorable
Lisa post who has the distinction of
being the prime sponsor of the bill and
she was off doing some OS business
weren't you just now and and uh your
predecessors in the hot seat did a
and you can take the questions as to how
bill up I'm sorry for the record my name
is Lisa post and I represent liboro
Mount Vernon in New Boston
um as it has already been introduced um
should I just take some questions from
folks or you can tell us what the what
the big deal is and why it's important
and what how this helps the uh State of
New Hampshire do
better so
um I'm sure you've all seen the
amendment so I will start with um from
the beginning um this is very similar to
a bill that was passed um through this
uh committee but what this does it
actually strengthens the bill that
already went through so we're just here
to fine-tune some things um so this bill
provides that unless a parenting plan
specifically provides otherwise both
parents shall have access to all the
records information that are pertaining
to the child the bill further directs
the court to award parental additional
parenting parenting time in response to
the other parents
non-compliance with the parenting
schedule this bill also permits the
court to find a parent for
non-compliance with either the
obligation to share the records or to
comply with the parenting schedule now
with
that you've Pro probably heard a lot of
testimony where the parent doesn't get
the paperwork they have no way to
understand what their child is going
through and they don't have any
information so this way um putting it in
in statute will allow
parents to have both
access for medical records school
records um unless of course there is a
reason not to and that is not a part of
um it doesn't apply to people who have
already been um I don't want to say
um so sorry um that that are not abusers
or neglect or anything like that so
we're just looking at those um folks
that are trying to put together a
parenting plan that works for both
families um and the other part of this
um the ability for uh families to um
um have a parenting
schedule that um keeps the child in
touch with both parents equally and if
there's any time that a
parent creates a problem that causes um
the family to now be split and one
parent um wants to keep the child longer
than the other person um that they have
to
um comply with the law if they're not
doing anything wrong they should have
that same if the parent keeps that child
they have the same amount of time given
back to the person that was egged by not
having time with their child and as we
know and we've seen this a lot of times
when you've gone through um these
situations with people coming up and
testifying and talking about
how awful it is not to be able to see
your child not to be able to know what
your child is doing how he's doing in
school what his metal conditions are so
I am totally in support of this bill
because it's strengthens families the
parent child relationship it strengthens
and again it also when both
parties can get together and and allow
that child to get to know their
grandparents their aunts their uncles
and their
cousins and that keeps a family unit
that keeps the child healthy that helps
um any kind of mental instability that
child has by being torn apart and not
being allowed to see the other parent
time so yeah there's a question any
questions for the sponsor this is your
chance representative Panic you have a
great question chairman
uh thank you
representative for letting me ask you
this question I don't understand on um
page one line 29 under C where it says
shall occur on or before the second
anniversary of the date of the Court
finds the parent in contempt for non
compliance with the court ordered
parenting schedule why was second
anniversary chosen because sometimes it
takes the Court's uh while to um be able
to make those
determinations okay thank you
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here to
um and taking my question so you know we
did pass the bill um well through the
committee anyway last week and stuff
that even has like a fine and whatnot my
concern and my question is that when we
talk about you
know uh there's a question but if we if
we talk about the child who's been kept
from one parent and for a particular
amount of time and sometimes it can be
years which is incredibly unfortunate
and not okay but then we want that child
to go back with the other parent there's
even talk of maybe having to do some
kind of therapy or something to reunify
them now if we say okay you've been
without parent a for three years so now
you're going to go with parent B for the
same for three year or you've been
whichever you're going with that other
parent for another three years does this
not make the child more of a a pawn as
well as do more damage by saying that
we're going to give them back the time
that they've lost I feel like that's
maybe in the best interest of the parent
but not necessarily the
child okay so um with that I I
understand what you're saying but the
the fact of the matter is when a child
is ripped away from one of their parents
it's an
emotional um devastating situation for
that child however if they already have
we're looking at someone who's already
having a par a parental plan right to
work together and just one day out of
the blue they decide to keep the child
for extra time or whatever because
something has happened they have agreed
with one another um that
child suffers more by not seeing one
parent than the other so regardless of
timing children can make that up with
their parents by spending time with them
whether it's a year a week two years
that child needs its parent and needs to
know all the things that
um that their parent loves them just as
much as the other parent loves them and
it gives the family more stability when
they have to work together and generally
I would say people that have to go
through something like this and are
forced forced by the courts to um work
with each
other that makes them comply more and it
makes it easier for families and I I
believe we've heard this before in
testimony that that parents um kids do
better when both
parents are with them follow up so and
on that note wouldn't it be better to
instead of saying okay you've been away
from this parent for a year let's give
you to that parent for a year wouldn't
it be better to reestablish the
relationship or that parenting plan as
is so that they have meaningful time
with both of them immediately rather
than doing it back and forth so we don't
Define that in any way in this bill so
it's something that they are to work
together to figure out what that timing
is going to be there's nothing in here
that specifically states that that
parent has to have them at in one whole
ve swoop they can do it over time to
make up that
time representative D
Simon
thank you Mr chairman asked and
answered representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I have two
questions about um language in the Bell
and the the first one is on um line
seven which is um number two it says
accept as otherwise precluded by state
or federal law and then it talks about
um institutions and organizations being
required to provide records my question
is without if we don't list or parenting
plan in that sentence does section two
override the parenting pl's um rules
about who has access to records because
we know that the parenting plans
sometimes say listen this parent can
have all the records but this parent
can't have the therapist records because
it would be damaging to the child but
now we have section two saying to the
therapist you must give them that record
record unless state law says you can't
so I'm I'm questioning whether there's
an internal um discrepancy without
having parenting plan be one of the
reasons why a therapist or a doctor or
whatever wouldn't release the records so
I think that was purposely let uh left
out that that is not an obligation there
um when we Define every little thing
whether a doctor or a therapist or a
teacher or a counselor if we're telling
them every little thing they can't or
can
have is not is not really an issue
because we are only looking at folks
that are working together families that
are working together right with a
parenting plan which they make up right
their parenting plan with this they have
the ability to say because this is only
when this happens this this is only when
a parent has been agged by not having
the child right so so follow up to that
okay
follow I'll follow up set please thank
so the the the this section section
starting on on line S doesn't say you
only have access to your child's medical
records if the other person has withhold
your withheld your parenting plan or if
you're not in compliance it says you
have access and we're going to cause a a
consequence to institutions who don't
give you the records irregardless of
what your parenting plan says right
correct okay correct so and Mr chairman
if I could ask my second question you
may thank you on page two line two um it
says the court May impose a civil fine
of $500 for non-compliance where does
that go is that a fine to the court is
that a fine to the parent who is the
agreed
party I actually do not know the answer
to that I would believe that it went to
the
you representative Perez thank you Mr
chairman for allowing me to ask the
question thank you for taking my
question don't we already have parental
rights to have access to records and the
only time the parents don't have access
to these records is when someone is
accused of neglected or uh domestic
violence or child abuse may I ask that
question thank you yeah uh thank you for
that question so this is not for people
who are abusers right this is for people
that are working together uh it we
already have a an ability to
um have someone that has been an abuser
that they are no longer allowed to
participate in those kinds of things
whether they can't get their school
records or their their medical records
that is already a a separate issue from
here followup thank you
followup so you told me that this is
completely separate from the rights the
parents already
have so many times a parent whe when
they have a parenting plan and they're
trying to work together and one person
gets mad at the other and they have a
relationship maybe one of the family
members the the mother or the father
grandmother whatever um if that person
um feels like that
the other person is not doing what they
want them to do or they're upset with
them in some way they can go and and uh
say I don't want you know my child's
record shared with this person the
husband the grandmother Whoever has the
child and how that works um and and they
will the schools will do that for these
folks and then the other one who there's
been nothing um uh uh that person has
not had uh been uh denied access to that
child that person still has the ability
to get it but the schools won't give
them or the doctor won't give them
because the mother or the
father are are saying nasty things about
each other so I believe that happens
quite a bit follow
up um so with this bill as schools can
be punished to pay penalties or anyone
who doesn't give the records to the
parent no I don't believe there's
penalties on that it is this is a way to
um it says shall right and not May and
that with that language it strengthens
comply represent
Bickford thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here with us take my question
um I I am looking at this and tell me if
I'm right or wrong as kind of an
intermediate thing between is it 633
that's a criminal uh for interference
with custody which I heard the
discussion go on about somebody takes a
child for three years naturally the
other parent would report it to the
police and sometimes the police do
something about it I've heard a lot of
times they don't don't but anyway that's
under the criminal code whereas this is
civil and would be much I would say
softer you know like a first step so I
wouldn't expect this to be the long-term
interference but more of a shortterm
wouldn't it be excuse we're making this
a question so wouldn't it be okay thank
you he has a good point it should be
okay
good
anyone else with a question for the
prime sponsor saying none thank you so
much will we address the amendment at
all yes in the exec session okay
meanwhile we can all read it furtively
on our own thank you're
welcome chair recognizes one of our
frequent flyers uh Mr Dana
albre and um you said you're going to
speak in three minutes but you have
tantalizing wow you always come with so
much useful information you know
chair so uh what's being passed around
now is uh two
exhibits uh which are very brief uh so
it's my hope you actually have time to
look at those uh which I believe speak
to the sort of two separate pieces of
the bill so the first is a simple
one-page uh police report uh with some
redactions as
appropriate uh that speaks for the need
for timely
resolution uh uh of a Judicial
enforcement of parenting plan under RSA
461 uh
a4a uh which this uh Bill seeks to amend
uh as well as uh I believe House Bill
106 uh and the second
one uh is an email exchange with some
schools counselors and
providers uh also appropriately redacted
to speak to the other part of this bill
or the need for it on
records uh
so let me Begin by saying that uh rights
on paper that can't be enforced are
pretty
useless
and as it stands right now the New
Hampshire state supreme court has
construed RSA 461
a4a as it is currently in statute is uh
not requiring much of
anything they've uh said we can go years
without holding a
hearing uh on a request for enforcement
and that's just fine with
them
uh
and uh so if you have a look at
the uh police report the issue with that
is the uh other party
here uh advised the Sierra California uh
Sierra moderate police in California she
had full custody of my minor children
when that was not in indeed the case and
I'm communicating with the school in
police to find out why they've gone
missing for 3
Days uh one would think it would be a
simple matter to run into Family Court
to sort of sort this out but uh years
later no hearing has ever been held on a
simple and task to enforce the parenting
plan in that case to the contrary it's
gone up to the uh state supreme court
who said per the current statute that um
no they didn't have to have a hearing
which is why we need to amend it and
most
recently uh I've even asked the US
Supreme Court for review that's doit 23-
6646 uh you could look that up online if
you want to read all 60 pages of orders
or somebody wants a copy I can give it
to you but that's by
request uh and the same for the petition
itself so
again uh that just really speaks to the
need to amend the statute so we can have
timely resolution of these
matters uh with regard to the second
part of the bill on
uh in email
exchange uh there's a bunch of people
here but some things I would point out
to you is even though the parenting plan
granted me full access to my children's
records the principal of the high school
says if I need anything I have to go
through mom to facilitate requesting and
that's kind of contrary to what my
parent in plan
said uh when I'm trying to get
appropriate Medical Counseling
records I am essentially uh ghosted by
the provider for a period of months it
went up to a complaint you know at the
regulatory
level uh in the state of Michigan and
now five months later I actually do have
some simple records with what should
have been a simple request going to give
you about a minute and a half
more um I think I'm mostly done I will
just uh speak briefly to something rep
Greg
raised uh on the do we want to go back
and forth you know three years or
not uh don't really have a huge position
on that but I'd refer that the Supreme
Court in Miller of vdd sort of said that
if you
go with willful intent to withhold a
parent it's strongly it's essentially
child abuse on the part of the
withholding parent any question done for
questions any questions from Mr
albre well thank you and I owe you 30
seconds the next time you're here thank
you chair recognizes representative
Timothy
Horgan
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
much for the to the uh members of the of
the committee I represent Timothy Horan
from straford County District 10 and I
first heard about the parenting time and
I'm opposed to the bill although I mean
the concerns behind it are valid but
this build isn't the right vehicle and
doesn't go about fixing them the right
way but anyway the years ago I served
something called the petitions and
redress committee which former speaker
Bill
O'Brien founded and it was mostly uh
family law cases where uh one side
usually was a father could be some there
were some mothers who came in from one
person you know their ability to get
along with their co-parent and raise
their children was they were impacted by
what long running disputes between the
two parties and this uh will probably
those
disputes happen before the committee me
and it happened since since the
committee existed and they're still
going on but I'm not sure uh this bill
is a bad way of going about fixing it
because there our um first of all the
whole thing about equal parenting time
misses the point to the main purpose to
have any parenting time with each your
parent is for the good of the children
so it's not primarily for the good of
the father or mother it's for the it's
for for the children so there may be
cases where the equal parenting time
there's many cases where that's not in
the best distance of the child the part
about any and all information even
though it is there is a clause about
precluding by state or federal law there
may be cases um if there's allegations
of abuse or other issues or if it's an
issue involving not just one kid but
some other some other
children um so I think this bill will
like force the schools and other parties
to divulge certain information which
normally they might not be divulging so
readily and possibly for for for for for
good reasons so I think and also um and
Alo the uh penalty even though it's a
civil penalty that can be quite
excessive especially you know these
things often go on these family law
disputes over parenting plans other
issues often go on for years some of
them even seen the manage to go on
somehow after the kid had already become
an adult and gone off on their own but
anyway that could be a very very large
find probably inappropriately so so I
would U let's so I would just say this
bill the problem IT addresses is real
but this is just not a very good
solution to the problem and um and I
also like I'm somewhat I'm also somewhat
dubious about the concept of equal
parenting time like managing down to the
minut because once again just to repeat
what I said already parenting time
mostly exists for the benefit of the
children so you know not it's not for
the benefit of the parents but thank you
so that's that's my testimony and I be
happy to take any questions if you have
them any questions no when you uh speak
representative to excessive fine I'm
assuming you mean page two yes lines one
two3 yeah $500 a day is that yeah I
would suggest that it is the court that
does it um and secondly it isn't
required to do it it may do it so
one would think perhaps it's an outlier
for court to rack up $500 fine a day
times five or six years what think yes I
would think that's an outlier so I hope
the courts aren't reasonable enough but
just in case you get a judge who's
judgment is poor um we don't want to let
him or her exercise too much bad
judgment in a case like that so thank
you thanks anyone else thank you
representative chair recognizes a former
representative Betty gay flown in a
great expense from Atkinson New
Hampshire excuse me Salem New Hampshire
come on
down would love to have her but Salem
neighbors I guess I'm supposed to say
I'm an honorable Betty gay The Honorable
Betty gay once a member of this
committee yes no always wished to be a
member of this oh that's right you
remember Health and Human Services when
I was there I remember that now yeah you
ahead okay um I support this bill I also
support the bill that y'all passed
already and many of you uh helped create
this just strengthens it um many
times well I don't know about many times
I'll just tell you my background very
simply is I received child support I
paid child support and when I got
married a second time I went through the
nightmare of not not ever knowing
anything about my stepdaughter her
mother did not want us to have anything
she wanted to be paid for medical bills
so she sent a page that was mostly
redacted it wasn't even even multiple
bills it was but my husband was trying
to be peaceful and and he paid but we
couldn't see anything so I understand
how critical it is to put into law very
clear directions about the rights of the
noncustodial parent to know as much as
possible about the child and to see and
spend time with their child because we
were denied from the time she was 14 we
never saw her until she connected when
she was
32 that's a terrific loss um the the way
this bill strengthens the bill that
y'all already passed is the one of the
sections just one of the things that it
said um that the courts may do we think
should be shall do and that is enforcing
the time for the child to be with the
parent that their court order says they
should have this doesn't rewrite the
court order it just says compliance
needs to happen it shall happen
um one of the problems that I saw other
parents nodding their head when somebody
made the statement while you have the
police to
enforce I don't know of any police force
that enforces the
visitation not any and I asked
specifically in my own police uh
Department who I trust greatly and their
feeling was we're not going to force a
child to leave if their other parent
comes to get them and they don't want to
and of course that puts them in a
position they need the authority you're
assuming they have authority they really
don't and it makes them have to be a
judge and a jury and a Psy psychologist
to figure out whether they should take
the child well we all know that it's
damaging to a child to be denied the
other parent unless of course that
there's abuse going on that's a real
serious issue that we all very concerned
about but abuse is not we're not talking
about abuse cases we're talking about a
case of a parent being furious at the
other parent and so they withhold a
child because that's their best best way
to get even for an unhappy marriage um
one one of the criticisms of this bill
was that they shouldn't say shall have
equal time because that was fixed but in
this bill if you look at line
26a it ends shall be the same type and
duration as the parenting time that was
denied or a reasonable approximation
thereof so it doesn't spell out exactly
how that compensation should be
calculated Rel ated are
created um and I thought line
29 uh as Panic said why is it second
anniversary well on one hand you could
say that's being really generous to the
withholding parent but we have to talk
about the reality of family court right
now and the delays are tremendous the
other the other uh thing that this bill
uh spells out is
um because of the delays and because
of accusations of abuse and this other
parents shouldn't have the child because
of this and this and this well that has
to be uh
studied the study can take months so
what this bill the the amended bill I
don't think it's spelled out right here
in the plain Bill dance around it but
don't be specific okay what what it
attempts to do
think if it's a false if it's a false
concern that takes us a few months to
set uh to determine that they really is
no reason the child should not be with
the other parent that other parent now
has lost all that time so what the what
this bill will do if
it's amended is is to grant that person
who missed out on their child's time
that time that they lose while it's
being studied is also included in the
lost is it your
experience um in the background to this
is chairing the special committee on the
Family Division of the Circuit Court it
was the testimony by people there that
the court would order something the
police wouldn't enforce it because they
said that's really the Court's business
and the court says we don't have an army
and it sort of lived in limbo do you
think this bill might help in some small
way to address that I think it's another
strong step toward that I mean next time
maybe we really need to put a bill in
that says the local police or the
sheriff's whatever whoever has the
authority in that uh place where it's
taking place that they really have the
authority and responsibility to enforce
it
repres I'll call Representative
Gibbons thank you Mr chairman
um I don't maybe you could explain how
you think that the police would be able
to uh enforce that because the problem
is that over the course of a child's
childhood there could be many uh
different orders that are written and
without a database to access what is the
most recent order then the the you know
some of these some of these types of
parents are malicious and they could
present old orders and say oh look this
is the order set and there's actually a
new order that's in there and the police
would at this point in time have no way
of knowing that so maybe you could
explain how you think that it would be
able to be enforced because I don't see
it as enforcable right now may I answer
yeah she both parents both parents have
so it's both parents can show the
policeman most recent order follow up
follow up that being said that's very
time consuming on the part of the police
to have to go between both parents and
the malicious parents not going to show
the most recent order if it's not in
their
interest so that's that's where we we
get into like a hangup where where it it
becomes he said she said well both
parents have orders that have dates on
them so the most recent date and what
we're hoping is that once this bill goes
once this goes into law the first couple
of people may try to test
it but if they found out that they're
going to hurt because they violated the
order then other people will learn it's
not really worth doing
we pay police to protect us and this is
a very serious painful thing that
happens to so many people because of the
maliciousness of some parents so it's
yes it's timec consuming but they
shouldn't have to go back and forth they
can be on one doorstep you show me your
orders let's see who's this current any
further questions for the retired
representative
seeing none thank you so much thank
good
afternoon Mr chair members of the
children and family law committee for
the record my name is Gail drat drat am
Hur New Hampshire I'm testifying in
support of this bill as our elected
policy makers each of you have the
greatest ability to reform outdated
laws and bring them into constitutional
compliance to better protect New
Hampshire children many New Hampshire
children have parents who share custody
after separation or divorce often times
after the parties have been to court and
have a court ordered parenting plan in
place one parent or the other May
interfere or obstruct custody by way of
keeping the the minor child on the other
parents court ordered parenting time
withholding them prior to a holiday or
perhaps make a false report of abuse or
neglect or domestic violence to be
vindictive or simply extend their own
parenting time improperly holding a
withholding a child is child abuse
during the investigation process of
these issues a child parent relationship
can be harmed investigations can and do
take weeks if not months the same holds
true for trying to get a hearing in the
Family Court allowing the obstructing
parent to withhold the child only on
precaution for extended periods of time
when the family court is taking a
parental right away only on precaution
and when they return the child and not
the time that was lost this becomes a
human rights issue more often than not
the reports are unfounded a 2021 study
noted that roughly 83% of abuse and
neglect reports that are investigated
ultimately Pro to be unfounded or
unsubstantiated among only those reports
that are made anonymously the number
Rises to
96% this means one out of every 25
anonymous calls leads to credible
evidence of Abus or neglect and many of
the 24 are knowingly false reports used
to weaponize the
system we also heard in the special
committee investigate in the Family
Court the former Commissioner of DCF
testified they received just north of
20,000 call to Central intake per year
just north of
10,000 are screened out and the other
10,000 are assessed or investigated for
abuse or neglect and they count in the
hundreds how many actually go to court
this bill seeks to remedy two concerns
that parents face after separation of
divorce and after having a lawful court
ordered parenting plan School
professionals one school professionals
are therapists withholding information
from one parent with a lawful court
order these actions harm children and do
not allow both parents equally to
actively engage in the care custody
education and upbringing of the minor
child and number two false reporting of
abuse neglect and domestic violence to
law enforcement or DCF this bill does
not allow any professional to disclose
records if the court order or parenting
plan makes Provisions for non-disclosure
and this bill does not allow
professionals to disclose information if
precluded by state or federal law the
provisions outline in part one of this
bill would not allow School
professionals doctors or therapists to
withhold information from either parent
or Ally with one parent section two of
this bill would dis disincentivize a
parent from withholding parenting time
or making false reports to law
enforcement or DCF knowing a court shall
order additional
parenting time to compensate for a
denial of court-ordered parenting time
resulted from interference with child
custody or result resulted from an
investigation by DCF that did not result
in a finding of abuse or neglect a
parent is less likely to engage in this
type of behavior knowing they will lose
portions of their own parenting time
this bill fixes a fundamental Liberty
and a parental right it brings healing
and allows child parent relation
relationships to be rebuilt from the
lost time that was taken only on
precaution by the court the parenting
time is returned only after the
allegations of abuse and NE or domestic
violence have been cleared this bill
allows resources to be used
appropriately and alleviates the already
overburden court system by stating in
this bill shall return the time instead
of May it shifts the burden of proof to
the defendant to prove why the time
should not be
restored thank
you will you take questions any
questions
um there will there will be a question
at the end of this
sentence I notice in line 8 it talks
about professional and then line 10
medical one of my day jobs as part-time
CEO of a medical and Counseling Center
so I have three primary care providers
under me and it initially bothered me
that they could be simply ordered to
Fork over the records MH but would line
13 at the beginning mitigate my fears
when it says without good cause if they
had good cause and I can think of a
number of good causes they would not be
held in any contempt for failing to hand
over records is that the import of the
phrase without good
cause I would say
yes thank you I don't have numbers on my
paper oh okay um
yeah if they're withholding it for good
cause and the parent can always go to
court and get a subpoena to have it
subpoena to court good thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and the chair calls
Denise
costlo oh okay that was a glasses
it okay thank you Mr chairman thank you
for allowing me to share parts of my
story with you today as I said my name
is Denise Costello I am retired having
spent the last 19 years of my career as
a pargal at the New Hampshire Department
of Justice Office of the Attorney
General I am a grandmother to maav and
Quinn who have been taken and isolated
from their loving mother and one half of
their family for no justifiable reason
for more than one
year interference with child custody and
shared parenting is an egregious
violation of parent of parental rights
that undermines parental Authority it is
a deliberate action by one parent to put
the children in the middle of a custody
dispute and it is detrimental to the
child's physical
emotional and mental
well-being it deprives a child of their
right to love and be loved by a parent
and one half of their
family interference with child custody
and shared parenting is Family Violence
and a child protection issue Mal
treatment of children used as Weapons
I'm going to stop you here you're
reading your testimony and we will be
reading it so therefore I'd like you to
summarize what you've got to say please
okay um well as a grandmother I am
appalled and shocked to learn of the
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
families that that live
through the tragedy that that we have
been living through you have no idea
what it's like there's not a day that
goes by that I don't miss my
grandchildren my husband and I don't
know if we will live long enough to see
them again and we will never get back
the lost time that's been taken from us
there are states that that make it a
misdemeanor and even a felony to
interfere with child custody and
parenting time I think New Hampshire
needs to step it up and have
consequences there are no consequences
children despite a court order a judge's
order and has not returned them our
journey through family court has been
filing a motion for contempt when it
happened his attorney filed an objection
to the motion for contempt the judge
said there was a hearing the judge
ordered the children to be returned to
my daughter on October 14th of 2022 we
again and down the rabbit hole we go
with the G and the hearings that are
rescheduled
and it's just been a nightmare I think
that some
accountability
for these people who are doing this to
the children is imperative and
consequences need to be there Justice
denied is in fact Justice delayed is in
fact Justice denied and they're getting
away with it legally they're getting
away with the abuse the post- divorce
abuse that's often times what what is
involved here
um
see give you about 30 seconds to wrap it
up I think your informal testimony for
me at least was more compelling than
reading a script I'd like to say that I
pray that you take the collective power
that you have been given to affect this
important necessary legislation to defer
to deter interference with child custody
and parenting time and the absolute
devastating effects it has on children
and fam
we will be executing this bill on March
5th and that gives a couple of weeks for
any changes and and so on to take place
it would be helpful for me perhaps
others if in the interim you would be
able to provide specifics to your
statement that some states have
penalties you had said that um I'd like
to see a little print out as to what
states do what on this and a good
paralal research project I think it
would be wonderful send it to the
committee I'd like to see what others do
I send it to your attention uh sure they
can pay attention too any other
questions representative McMahon thank
you Mr chairman U just a point of class
um clarification ma'am the um other
party uh here where does uh where does
the father reside coner New Hampshire
okay and I I just in clarification I
asked that to ensure there there wasn't
a reciprocity issue with another state
in in dealing with the law so so both
entities reside in the state of New
Hampshire in conquered correct thank you
very much anyone else representative
McMahon I
representative
La thank you your
honor you may proceed thank you uh Mr
chairman uh so the order of October of
22 was the child did you get to visit
the child or or did the mom get to visit
the child did he did he comply with that
order no he has not no okay so he didn't
all right thank you the mom is right
here
too seeing no further questions thank
you so much for your testimony and I
look forward to that little book report
thank you thank
you and see having no further except for
representative Perez who wants to ask a
question
of um no I just don't want to um ask
question but I would love to say thank
you for everyone who came and
testify um as someone who um went
through the same
um issue that we dealing in here um my
son he was very little when um did a
court give us a joint custody in my
ex-husband took both of my kids to North
Carolina um but I didn't know my rights
and to that point so I I learned until
my son he was almost 18 years old that I
learned that I had the right to have my
ex-husband bring my kids back to new
hire from North Carolina but uh thank
you for testimonies that I heard today
thank you for that representative I
think that brings some comfort to know
that you understand
all right with that this concludes the
um hearing on House Bill
1659 uh again for the purpose of the
committee and anyone else February 20th
next week what we're going to do is
already listed in the calendar which is
available online it'll be in there again
on Friday February 27 is vacation March
5th we're going to have a big exec
session on the various things that we
have heard to date with that I reopen
the hearing on um house bills 1650 no I
don't I reopen the hearing
on 1027 relative to allowing child
support to include the period of
pregnancy and uh we are reopening that
hearing it has been introduced already
by representative patrino and there's
your bill
uh before you take a look is there
anyone here testifying on this bill the
prime and only sponsor of the bill is no
longer a state representative he
resigned the house last Friday and uh
here's the bill and I'm at your pleasure
on what to
do yes representative Molson thank you
Mr chairman so if he's no longer a state
representative then what's the pro
process how can he have a bill here he
doesn't the bill on first reading came
to us in January it's been our bill
remember that time when they all talked
fast and nobody paid attention that was
when the bills went from in effect the
custody of the Prime sponsor to the
Committees so this has been our bill
since but then someone has to adopt it
some is what representative Petrino
introduced it so we're now having a
anybody want to say anything about this
on the committee I do who is I do oh you
Perez you do yes I I have a lot to say
about this bill because okay uh to be
honest if um we not allow in or like
make it difficult for
um sexual assault victims to have an
abortion well
they the Dad should be responsible to
pay child child support they you know
they don't wanted um females to to have
the right to decide what's happening
with their body so the parents should be
responsible to pay child support if they
wanted
push the mother to continue the
pregnancy even when she wasn't even
wanted to have that child but she was
pushed by sexual soul to carry that
baby that's all I has to say thank you
for your your comments representative U
Panic thank you uh chairman um and I'd
like to say
that the mother has a choice up to the
month of uh was it 24 weeks 24 weeks
yeah 24 weeks to choose to have an
abortion so that choice is still given
to the mother up to six
months um would you not think the father
has any respon if if known the father
has any responsibility for costs
incurred by the mother or can the father
just say see you later well
where she's talking about a rape
situation you know who your rapist is
sometimes sometimes sometimes yeah
that's true we don't always know that
and then there's another are area that
gets a little gray is sometimes the F
they don't know who they don't know who
the father is so that's hard to
prove until after the birth am I correct
I'm not a
nurse thank you um yes there I I believe
because I've I've read through all of
the um actual statutes in this state I
believe that they do have to establish
per uh paternity after birth right so
that would make it difficult
to implement this if a paternity hasn't
been established it would make it
youbody
else
is it the pleasure of the committee to
go forward to execute or do you want to
sit on it for a couple weeks all in
up either thumb will do okay all in
favor of proceeding to an exact session
on this
thumb well all right I'm ending the um
hybrid uh whatever we just did
kind of a on
1027 and I'm now opening the exec
session on
and representative Perez would you like
to make a motion you don't have to but
I'm going to give you first shot at it
like and if you don't want to I will
call on you again
sometime um I would like to make a
motion to
um
pass this bill OTP OTP
OTP I'm sorry
OTP you want a bill to pass that's an OT
it I'm sorry you don't want it to pass I
want it it sorry you don't want it to
tired you're among friends
here and representative Greg second's
itl now we can do what you did and speak
about it if you
wish I passed thank you that's all right
you you gave a good talk go
representative long I see somebody wants
to speak on
it representative LEC yeah I think that
it's don't pronounce all the
letters I think it's kind of hard to
with standing law and with this bill it
kind of contradicts of how to determine
paternity when you have to do it after
the birth so they can't exactly
determine child support when paternity
isn't determined until after the child
is
born and this kind of contradicts the
law and I think that we can all agree to
that thank you
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman yeah there's a lot of problems
with this bill um first of all they did
it in 10 lines too right first of all it
if we're if we're talking about
establishing child support then that
opens up the door as to abortion rights
which other people have mentioned um
because you can't say that
there's you know that there's child
support and also the right to abort it
it those are in conflict with each other
we've already mentioned the
um sorry I I lost what I was saying we
already mentioned issue with paternity
but then also um if if we're talking
about the medical bills I'm not sure if
that's already in standing law I do
realize that there's a lot of medical
bills but there's also financial
assistance available at hospitals if um
and they can also deal with that after
the birth uh because you don't have to
prepay for services you can be on like
payment plans so um you know they they
could always like deal with that after
the fact I believe so I would suggest
that a pregnant woman who irrespective
of marital status is acting single
because with this guy go to has other
bills besides medical bills and there's
something in me having met at least my
share of deadbeat dads who everybody
knows who the father is and this uh low
life will not lift a finger to help
whatsoever I really would not my
mechanism that would just grab him and
twist him until he's a pretzel
um I'm trying to be polite because I I'm
thinking far worse than what I just said
um but I think it gets complicated in
some of the other stuff they're asking
for darn it I was hoping we could find a
way to make the dead beats pay but I
don't think this is the vehicle anybody
else there is
side
hooray you are more fascinated than I
you I may it just reminds me of my days
when I was sick at home watching the uh
whatever Murray show that was the uh oh
you
know vacuum tubes
[Laughter]
please I think we're ready to roll here
the motion before us is on House Bill
1027 it was moved by representative
Perez who's going to write the blurb and
you can write it in Spanish just to just
to make them learn okay and seconded by
representative Greg uh the motion is itl
would the clerk please call the role
that I'm really allowed to do that
Mr yeah well you got to put in English
subtitles for those who are not well
educated okay I can do that definitely
can do that go for it I will sign off on
that I'll bring it back to my wife to
just cuz she reads Spanish okay the
motion's itl a yes motion means you want
to kill the bill or yes answer so I'll
um please call a ro chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
disimone yes representative bford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative grman is absent
today representative L yes
representative Patrina will be voting
yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg
representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond yes 15 to zero
look at that you carried the
day and the house rule representative
Perez is he needs to have your committee
report before you leave
consent yes consent and oh good for you
bit
this closes the executive session on
House Bill
1027 uh I now open the executive session
on House Bill
1308 and that is relative to parental
access to Children's Library records and
and you should have with you uh copies
of amendment 202
24-58
5H uh written by the uh the prime
sponsor of the bill so as you take out
the um the bill make sure you have the
amendment um take a look at the
amendment in the first order of business
is a motion on the amendment so take a
anybody need a copy of the amendment got
brief
chair will entertain a motion on the
amendment I see a hand that looks like
it's representative Raymond's hand thank
you Mr chairman I know I'm kind of
hidden over here um do we have to move
the amendment no you don't have
to it is presented to you if no one
wishes to move the amendment the
amendment
dies
B can you put your mic on I couldn't
hear you she usually tells me she's
busy she's busy writing a blurb well I
I'm just say I I think the mo I think
it's a better what's your motion ought
to pass the amendment the amendment
ought to pass is there a second on the
Amendment representative Panic just beat
you I second the motion ought to pass
okay now discussion on the
amendment I uh I've been opposed to this
right along but mostly it's because of
the libraries having the secrecy uh
thing um I um we
learned that a parent can be in control
by just using a family card or their own
card uh but if if they are silly enough
to not do that and give it to the child
I'm beginning to think maybe it's not
such a bad idea so I'm willing to listen
to to debate as to why not do this why
not do what uh the amendment which is
which is to give uh parents the right to
look at what their children are take
records in the library it wouldn't
include when they go to the library and
look at stuff it would only be when they
record uh make a record of something
which is generally a library
card that's the only thing I think
of
Representative
Gibbons thank you Mr chairman I still
need a seating chart here sorry yeah no
it's okay uh it takes a while to and I
and my name plate still hasn't changed
so there's that well yeah but you've
studied enough gerontology to know that
this sort of happens when yeah thank you
you're fine go ahead um
so here's the here's the thing I
understand that the with the family card
they can see everything but if a child
is or I I should say a minor because
this is really going to apply to like
the teenagers and stuff if they're
really that bent on the parent not
seeing what they're accessing in the um
in the library just imagine the scenario
imagine that you know rep is my daughter
and I say here here's my it would take
imagination but go ahead she is right
next to me so I'm just using her as a
prop and she hasn't mine um but you know
if I say here's the family card and she
goes and takes it there's nothing
mandating that she actually uses it she
can go to the library and just kind of
have this in her you know purse or
whatever and just open her own library
card so and then if I questioned like oh
it doesn't look like you took anything
out she can be like nope and there's
nothing guaranteeing that they're going
to to
use the family card just because I
provide it to them so why would we even
bother with this
spill representative long I'm still
getting my mind thank you Mr chairman uh
so there's 234 libraries each of them
have their own governing body so this is
an issue for that governing body if I'm
living in Manchester and I don't like
something then I'm going to go to my
library and I'm going to say I have an
issue I'm going to go to my Alderman or
whatever and say I have an issue with uh
not getting uh a book that my son is a
year behind is a
year uh over and bringing it back I you
know this is not I in my opinion I don't
think this is a state issue I think it's
a governing body for each particular
library that would be Trustees for the
library correct yeah representative
panic
um I respectfully disagree with you
representative long and um South
Carolina has um cut their ties with the
American Library
Association and so has it Montana and
Texas and the reason being is that
um parents are not being given access to
their minor children children's reading
material they are told to monitor the
internet on what they're seeing
online but when it comes to monitoring
what kind of books they're taking out
it's a big secret and this is the reason
why they're cutting ties with the Ala
it's the Ala that is directing the
libraries what to
do and the problem
is we have a lot of
pornography that is
being put into
the children's library and the kids have
access to stuff that should be adult
content and I don't think it's the
government's business or the ala's
business or our public libraries
business to be putting thems in a
situation to be teaching our minor
children about the birds and the bees
that's stripping away a parental right
and I believe that a parent has the
right to determine what would be
appropriate for that child's age
category and to representative Gibbons I
don't think a child a minor child can
take out their own library card without
a parental signature am I correct about
that representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh so again a
library is not a babysitting facility so
if I don't trust my kid what they're
doing in the library I'm not sending the
child to the library it's it's that
simple you know I'm gonna I'm going to
look for places for my child to go but
however I want them to video and monitor
him and give me every everything you
know about him no that's my
responsibility if there's something I'm
not going to know about them then that
that child's not going going
there anyone else representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman so on this subject
and and you know back to the babysitters
and the parents and all that this is the
conversation that you have with your
children part of a par parental right is
to be able to have a conversation with
your child about what they're reading
and what they're doing not to oversee
them like the FBI and go behind their
back and say I'm going to look at your
records and stuff we should be having
those conversations but another
complication in a bill like this is our
libraries are not set up to be able to
even handle this kind of a a demand on
them and I'm not sure where the money
would come from for this kind of a a
mandate for them to do something like
this even though I I find it
inappropriate in the beginning because
it is a locally um local thing that they
do not a state thing but anyway there's
so many complications to this bill and
so many reasons why this is a bad idea
I'll I'm I'm in favor of itl on this
represent ative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman
um we've heard and here and I've heard
um that um libraries have all sorts of
um databases and there are a lot of
libraries who um do not have uh the
capabilities to go back in time and um
the section
uh on line five um section 2A all
Library records um is a problem because
it doesn't give us a specific time frame
for that um so that's one of the
problems that I have with the Bill thank
you representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman during
testimony I raised the question so if a
child doesn't want their parents to know
what they're taking out from the library
there's nothing that stops a child from
going down the aisles and taking a book
off the shelf and sitting in a corner
and reading for 20 minutes without the
parent even knowing so I mean in that
sense if I know that Mom and Dad are
checking on what I'm reading guess what
I'm never going to take the book out and
parents actually should be happy that
kids have library cards and they're
going to the library in the first place
reading representative
LC
I'm pretty young when and I kind of
remember my mom and my dad taking me to
the library and actually having full-on
discussions of what is appropriate and
what's not when I would bring him a book
that I wanted to read and they would my
mom would sit down and read the back at
least and skim it and she'd be like okay
this is why it's not I don't feel it's
at your age level go find another book
and she'd be finding a book that she
wants to read while I'm over in the kids
section and she's with me my parents are
with me every time you go to the library
you can't just leave your kid unattended
to go wandering the library they have to
have an adult somewhere in the library
you are you see a kid anywhere and
you're like where's your parents where's
your mom and dad and they say right over
there then you're like oh okay it's
great if they say my parents are at the
grocery
store that's kind of problematic for any
adult in that situation of like okay can
you call them and get them here
or uh if they don't show up in the next
30 minutes we're going to call the
police because you are an attended child
and that's the whatever protocol that
they have to
follow representative D
Simon thank you Mr
chairman I think the concept of this
bill is
awesome I truly do however I think this
is the wrong
place there are
234 libraries in this state none of us
know what capabilities all those 234
libraries
have none of us know how much funding
those libraries
have and none of us know what those
particular
communities
mindset toward what children can and
cannot take out and the
parents involvement with those
children I I do like the concept of the
bill but I think that it should be a
municipal warrant article for each
individual Community to deal with in
their own
Community taking into cons consideration
the financial constraints the Staffing
involvement which one am I the chair
daughter thanks Mom thank you Mr
chairman um just uh I forgot where I was
you got bra on the daughter's not
thinking straight
um what we're finding what what we found
in our town is the on a local level the
library trustees are not listening to
the people that are complaining about
what is going on within their Library so
I
agree that we want to keep it in in the
municipalities but what do you do when
when the trustees the people that are in
charge of it aren't listening and
they're still promoting and pushing
right in the front row of the kids are
seeing it every time that to
representative panic's comment on the
obscene materials that should not be in
front of a child and they are right
there when you enter the the the grounds
or enter a room that that is not off
child Mr chairman I would like
representative deimon thank you I think
that in that case if you had a warrant
article that was passed in your
municipality then you go to the library
and say excuse me librarian there is a
town ordinance or city ordinance that
says that you have to provide me this
information
otherwise that I just again I don't want
to put libraries in a position where we
are legislating them to spend more money
than what they have and try to hire the
staff that they can't afford to hire yet
another Community can hire that staff
another Community can put in all of
what is necessary to monitor I'm all for
monitoring those kids absolutely 100%
and we'll work with the sponsor of this
bill to um if this does not pass I will
work with her to write uh a warrant
article for next year's um town meeting
and get this passed in our
community representative
Raymond um thank you and I just want to
point point out that libraries are
public facilities akin to a museum we
would never drop off a child at a mum
and let them run around without parental
supervision it is the obligation of
parents to guide their children to
activities media and books that are
developmentally appropriate for their
own child it is not the responsibility
of the library staff any more than it
would be the responsibility of a museum
staff to censor what they offer the
public it is the parents job to
supervise their child and if your child
is not developmentally able to follow
your family values then they are not
developmentally able to be in a place
without supervision that's I mean that's
the bottom line and that's a parenting
decision
so representative
Perez thank
you Mr chair for to speak I agree with
uh representative dong
um just to put an example our library in
Milford is falling apart we don't even
have enough money to fix the
infrastructure issues with the public
library in Mur might as well putting
more burning into spend money and other
issues that we don't really if the
parents already have you know if the
parents spending already enough time
with the children when they go to the
library we should not be needing these
kind of bills here at the child and
family La committee thank you
representative
panic I don't see in this bill or the
amendment um are we talking on the
amendment or the bill you're talking
about the amendment I don't see anything
in the amendment or the bill that would
be in an
additional financial burden to the
community or the library when when
representative
um quo I can't say your name correctly
the reason what she brought this bill up
is
because when the parents would get a
overdue notice from the library the
library was not
allowing does not allow the librarian to
tell the parent what book is
overdue so all this does is lift the
veil and you know I I don't see how that
would be an additional financial burden
and if this material this pornography is
in the
libraries I don't understand in the
children's
section and sexual hypersexualizing our
children at an early age I don't
understand why everybody is okay with
this
I we're robbing our youth of their
childhood of their innocence and what is
the point of that what do we gain out of
that and that's what I and I'm really
upset to see
that this is
continuing to be able to go on and I
think South
Carolina and um Texas and Montana are
doing the right thing by stopping them
and I think we ought to get in line with
with this that's all I have to say
presentative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman I
absolutely am not in favor of providing
an appropriate material or pornography
to Children uh I have
heard um from
libraries and we I think we have in
written
testimony that in order to provide um um
this information that libraries will
have to expand their database in one way
or another and that is what would be one
of the things that would be costing
money and um the therefore this actually
mandate representative
Raymond um I was going to point out uh
what representative Nelson said so I
appreciate that um and the other thing I
will say is again we cannot replace
supervision of kids with government
surveillance if you want to know what
your child is reading you need to be
there with them when they check it out
and you need to be able to have these
conversations and I say this as a parent
of teenagers I know what my kids are
reading I've known what they've been
reading since they were children and
there are children's library books that
different people disagree about the
appropriate
and that's okay it's okay for different
families and different individuals to
have differing opinions on what is
appropriate for their own
child so having said that what I allow
my child to read may not be what another
parent wants their child to read and
that's okay but it is not the library's
responsibility to Monitor and make those
decisions it's the parents
responsibility and if you have very
strong feelings if you genuinely believe
that there is pornography in the library
then you should not be allowing your
child to access the materials without
your guidance and supervision if your
child is bringing home library books
you're not aware of what they checked
out how many books they have whether
it's gotten lost then your failing in
your responsibility as a parent to
provide adequate supervision to your
child that's the bottom line I mean we
have to hold parents to a standard of
parenting here not the
government representative sidel's mother
thank you Mr chairman
um uh I should make a list of how many
different nicknames I'm getting in this
session but anyway
um I just want to say I think it's a bit
disrespectful to the libraries to say
that there's pornography in the
children's section because that's not
the case um porn Ry is an actual
classification of books you're
not I'm just saying don't even don't
even
say
I'm just my point is just that that's a
specific
genre and that's not in the children's
the
I'm going to move the question I think
we are kicking this to death um so the
question before us is on the
amendment
585h on House Bill 1308 the amendment
was moved out of pass by representative
Bickford and seconded by representative
Panic with the clerk call the rooll
please a yes vote is for the
amendment chairman Pearson yes
representative long no representative
disimone yeah representative
bigford representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Sidell yes
representative Gman is not here
representative LC no representative
Patrina will vote no representative
Perez
no representative
Greg representative Gibbons no
representative Raymond no I believe it's
8 to
seven
eight five six seven 8 to S the
amendment carries 8 to7 chair will
entertain a motion on the bill as
amended I see the hand first of
Representative Raymond I move
itl Raymond SE uh moves uh Petrino
seconds a motion of
itl any ASM uh yeah itl um any further
discussion and please say
no when the clerk is ready the motion is
0585 chairman Pearson the motion is itl
yes representative long yes
representative
ton yes representative
bfid representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic no Representative sidel no
representative Gman is absent
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Perez absolutely yes representative Greg
yes representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond yes 13-2 on itto
13-2 on itl representative Raymond don't
do what the chairman did last time and
instead get your report in
today and I want to note a minor miracle
that I've just experienced up here I
asked representative
Perez to write the committee report in
Spanish and I'm looking at this and I
can read every word of it I am I'm
learning Spanish well let me tell you
something I'm very I'm true a langual I
speak Spanish English and Portuguese so
yes I'm more than happy to do it in any
any of those three languages you would
like
to Mr chairman yes do we want consent is
there going to be a Minority Report I'm
going to ask that one of the ones who
do um
but if either one of you who voted no
wishes to write a Minority Report please
turn it into the
clerk
consent no no I'll object to consent I
floor would you like me to pass these
out to my
friends wow I mean I don't need 16
copies but thank you uh let's make some
of them go this way and all of them go
that way wait a minute we leave when you
leave Mr
chairman right
behind this ends the exact session on
representative bigford you're getting
some stuff handed your way uh keep it
going please Whoever has all of these
that are being passed around keep going
repes representative Panic to the right
thank you the other right that way and
representative bigford there'll be a
superfluity of them please Trot them
over to
representative's
Mother
yeah I know I don't I know I don't have
to be but I can be she's going to get a
kick out of it it's a good thing yeah
I'll need one and she gets right on the
camera
too the uh handout that's coming around
is some questions about um child support
researcher I am now opening the exec
session
on House Bill 1392
House Bill
1392 and our very own representative
Gibbons um will do your daughter proud
and introduce yes this for us this is an
exact session correct so this amendment
that I uh presented to you uh if you
remember when I introduced the bill I
told you that uh chairman Pearson got me
in touch with a lawyer who um um her
name is Aon KGAN she represents the
court symptoms symptoms uh systems sorry
and I know right and she I was waiting
at the time I was waiting for her to
Circle back to me uh because she
mentioned that if the child testifies in
private uh to the judge then it
presented an app pellet issue because
the parents would have would not have
access to all of the evidence in their
own uh case so I presented it at at that
and we were not we did not execute at
that time because I was waiting for her
response well she responded back to me
and she recommended the language that is
in italics here um and
I uh I asked her is so I sent it over
over to OSS and when I got it back from
OS I gave it to her to look at and I
said what do you think she approved of
the language and I asked
her what if one parent consents and the
other parent doesn't and she said that
could happen however she does not
anticipate it happening because it would
look really bad to the
parents um and the judge would could see
who consented and who didn't um so it's
always a possibility because people can
do kind of crazy things um but it would
be bad for them to do it so she didn't
expect it so I left the amendment like
committee
sure um okay
so so the therapist gives an opinion to
the
court is
that is that information going to the
parties
yes okay so I would say that with the
consent of the parties if that report is
opposing me I'm not giving
consent whether it happens rarely or not
I don't believe it's gonna happen rely
I'm G to look at this and say no I don't
want this in so the therapist's opinion
is just can the child can the child is
the child mature enough to testify to
the Court yes or no
basically um so that's the report for
the most part yes so that so a piece of
paper is going to say the child is
mature enough to testify yes that's the
point and because the that doesn't seem
like a report to me if you if you recall
what the purpose of this bill is this
bill is a gateway for the child to have
their right to be heard in court and
currently what what I found out in doing
the research is that G's are not funded
by the state and so they're only
accessible to families who can pay for
them and so judges are I'm just
recapping from from when I introduced
the bill judges are hesitant to bring
the child in to testify because it can
be traumatic to the child so we're in
this like cost benefit situation where
if they were to bring it in bring in the
child to the court to assess their
maturity Lev
on if we can you know have this child
testify in
court and then the judge determines that
the child can't because they're not
mature enough then you brought them in
you did trauma and you got nothing out
of it because you determin that the
child can't testify so the judges are
are are staying away from that entire
situation because they don't want to
cause any trauma to a
child so my idea was initially
to have the to have the therapist simply
state if the child has a therapist so
not demanding that one has one um if
that the that the therapist says that
the child is mature enough and so the
judge can get that testimony and say oh
this child is mature enough to testify
in court so let's bring them in and then
once the child is and and a school
therapist can do it too uh once the
child is in the court have the CH child
testify in the chambers and the purpose
for that is because the child would feel
more comfortable wouldn't it wouldn't be
as stressful of a situation for the
child and then also we wouldn't pit the
parents against each other and we
wouldn't have like outside influences on
the child the child can just and again
this is in a situation where they're you
know they're just wanting to craft their
own schedule where you know these kids
who are mature enough are presumably in
middle school and high school
um someone brought up an example if
they're on the football team and they
have practice every day how are you
going to how do you want the parenting
time to look like oh well I have
football until 5:00 well maybe I'll do
Monday and Tuesday with Dad and
Wednesday and Thursday with Mom or
something something but just to put the
control back into the hands of the child
because it is their life but still give
the parents equal parenting time but the
child gives their opinion so it's not a
demand an opinion about what that
parenting time looks
like because there's about 80 million
different ways that equal parenting time
can look
like representative D
Simone thank you Mr
chairman
basically the bill and the amendment
makes sense however to representative
Long's
know older mature children are very
manipulative so if Mom is the more
strict parent and dad is the more fun
parent this child's going to want to go
to Dad and Dad's and Mom's going to say
I'm not going to okay
this so I don't care how mature my child
is I don't
agree so this bill does not address what
the judge would ask the
child um
so
basically the child would have to have
equal parenting time or however the
parenting time is
ordered and the goal here is just for
the child to have a little bit of a say
in what happens as far as like when
they're with their mom and when they're
with their dad not if they're with their
mom or with their dad that's the judge's
determination so I'm not
foreseeing a situation where it's like
oh I'm mad at my mom so now I only want
to spend time with my dad because I'm
foreseeing a situation where the child's
going to spend time with
both and this is just
crafting what it's going to look
like and that I think that's the
impression that Aaron crean got as well
who's that that attorney who actually
spoke to the family law judges and came
back with this
language so you know anything that that
requires o adult only assessment is left
to the parents and the judge this is
kind of like the Minor Details so it
sounds to me like the child who is the
guest of honor in all of these things
actually gets a little bit of standing
in
court that's that yeah because the child
has a right to be heard that that is
what the the studies actually say that
the child has a right to be in other
words we shouldn't overthink this all
this is is not to diminish you a simple
thing right it's not that the judge has
to if if the judge determines like oh
this child might be being manipulative
that's on the judge to determine I'm not
I'm not saying what the judge has to
order I'm just saying I want the judge
to be able to talk to the child and then
the child to give their opinion and the
judge to use that opinion not
necessarily have to order according to
the child's opinion but just use that as
another piece of information that's
coming in piece of
evidence representative
ball thank you chairman parison and
thank you for bringing the amendment um
I do
have a couple concerns and I think I
brought them up before because it
already says that the judge can consider
can give do consideration to other
factors right and all of this input
would be other factors great um so
that's the one thing the other is this
is saying therapists and you say it
could be a school therapist but it
doesn't say that so it's very vague as
to what is a therapist um I'm not really
sure what a therapist is um the other
thing is um you mentioned that they
can't afford a j but who can afford a
therapist so I'm kind of I'm hearing
like mixed things going on and I like
the idea of a child having their opinion
but unfortunately their opinion goes
this way in a very narrow focus and so
they can say well I want to be with Dad
on the nights I have football and dad is
saying okay but I got to get your
daughter my you know another child to to
ballet on that same night like just
because it's what they want it doesn't
necessarily in fit into the whole family
Dynamics I mean it's it sounds great if
you have an only child but if you're
dealing with multiple children it's
really the parents again going back to
our last thing of saying parents need to
know what's best for their child and now
all of a sudden we're saying well well
not in this case we're going to let the
child decide and I understand just give
their opinion but then I would go back
and say it's already covered in the in
the being able to consider the other
factors I think what you're bringing up
might be the case in some
situations um but that could be
addressed when the parties are talking
to the judge so in other words you know
the judge comes back and is like oh well
you know the child wants to spend
Fridays with Dad um whatever I don't
know I'm just making up something random
and and the dad says oh well I have
another child to do ballet with then
then the judge doesn't have to order
that you know I'm not I'm not saying the
judge has to order what the child's
opinion is I'm not saying that I'm just
puzzle representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman you know this
is I struggle with this because I you
know I I understand you know kids
needing to get H and stuff but you look
at no matter how mature a child is
whenever you have parents who have
divorced this is a very disruptive thing
so the whether or not they're mature or
not emotionally we've just put them in a
very you know bad position whether it be
that the parents weren't getting along
or whatever it's still disruption in
their life so to then give them this you
know Willy Wonka card of oh let's get
your opinion on it the the level of
difficulty that puts a child in whether
it be you know they have feelings of oh
I don't want to make this parent feel
bad or I don't want to make that parent
feel bad I just think it's really this
is inappropriate you know I once again
like I said before I think the judge you
know
has a job to look at the entire blanket
and see what's going on because even as
parents we don't always have insight
into how our what we're doing might
might affect that child but what we do
have is an obligation as a parent is to
protect our children and and sometimes
that's protecting them from putting them
in a very
um emotionally damaging situation with M
making them determine one parent or the
other could very well be that so that's
the reason why the child's going to
Chambers thank you but they still know
it's getting back to their parents and
and and by the way we might have a
parent that's not really very
emotionally mature that's going to say
so why did you say that you want to be
be with you know your mom all this time
and not me this is not this is a a child
is never a tug-of-war rope it should
never be and and our committee this is
what we should be looking at what is
best for the child and I do not see you
know pivoting them in this as being best
for the child in any any which way so
just to answer your
question not a guarantee that the judge
would disclose everything that the child
says
because that language isn't in there and
also just as a reminder that the the
language representative
sidel thank you Mr chairman um my in
reading this it's already in statute
that the court is going to it's up to
the evidence that the minor child has
sufficient maturity the child a lot of
these times are is already going to
testify is already going to speak speak
at least to the judge they're not isn't
this just another no so the child that's
the whole point that's what we're that's
what we're addressing is that the child
is not being brought in at all at all
okay because it was my understanding
that this this is just adding the
therapist's opinion to help the child
this is a pathway to bring the child in
because the child is not being brought
in okay because the the
underlying uh issue is that bring the
the child in may cause trauma to the
child or
stress I to use a better term I think it
would be stress but some of the studies
I was reading said trauma so um so
because it's a stressful situation for
the child the judges tend to not bring
them in and that's where we get into
this
issue representative
long uh thank you Mr chairman so um so I
understand what the problem is MH but I
don't see this fixing a problem cu the
judge May interview the child so you're
still going to have the problem the
judge is not going to interview the
child uh so what I see this I mean this
is just my opinion I see two parties
parents not being able to figure
something out let's turn it over to the
kid totally
inappropriate representative
Perez may I yeah thank you well the
problem that I'm seeing here is that we
already have a lot of child they already
traumatized and why do we want to put
this Shell through I'm more traumatized
by put them you know through the core if
they allowed you know already to testify
or they're already coming into the court
why do we need this kind of Bill to just
putting big things into that those shoes
that they they don't wish to be
especially minors why well because at
certain ages sometimes they do want to
testify um at at at different ages they
have different opinions uh but the child
does have a right to be
them representative
Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank you
representative given um I I see
something in the amendment anyway uh but
we're on the bill we're on the amendment
we're on the amendment thank you um that
I think adds confusion and that is where
it says
um at on line seven at the end of
responsibilities that speaks substantial
weight to the preference of the mature
minor child your what you've added to
the bill belongs there and the next
sentence should come afterwards because
the next sentence talks about something
else not about maturity it talks about
give due consideration to other factors
which may have affected the minor
child's preferences which is after the
fact which which is done after the uh
therapist and the consideration of
whether they're mature or child and a so
they should have been separated I
believe
there I mean maybe that's a housekeeping
issue but um the the the attorney and
the family court judges didn't see an
issue with
it well they
know having read law books like you
wouldn't believe in the last year I find
sometimes the narrative goes 1 3 2 four
five yeah so I'm not worried about that
representative uh somebody over here had
a hand
up around the corner or two
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman um I agree
with um representative Sidell and
sometimes I can't read my own
handwriting so
maybe maybe people can um maybe other
people remember I thought we did hear in
testimony that it was up to the judge's
discretion to determine maturity and
that's what we're trying to
help right but they're not doing it so
that's why we're trying to help so it so
yep go ahead so how would this um
increase the um ability for the child to
because it's taking the assessment piece
off of the
judge which is that that's where the
hiccup is and it's a it's a wellknown
problem I think because that attorney
krian was saying that this is a uh this
affects a lot of
cases okay I'm going to hope that no one
has a hand up and we're going to do
something now that we should have done
before we're going to ask somebody to
move the amendment we've just
discussed all right and who's going to
Second the Amendments uh I will second
the
amendment this is where normally
discussion would come but it's not
coming right now
motion
do a motion to move the amendment in
what way OTP thank you is he happy now
yeah yeah good I'm glad you're
yeah the motion before us is on
Amendment
20240 579 H to House Bill
1392 the motion is a to pass moved by
representative G Gibbons in second by
the chair with the Kirk clerk please
call the role Jim Pearson yes
representative long no Representative
disimon no representative bfid yes
representative Nelson
no representative
McMahon representative
ball representative Panic yes
representative Sidell yes
representative LC no representative
Patrina will vote no representative
Perez no representative
Greg representative
Gibbons
yes
seven eight
it fails the amendment fails uh now we
have the bill unamended can I have a
motion on the original
bill I would move that the bill ought to
second well it's was that a
yes or or
stretch representative sidel is that a
second okay good okay so move give it
well I should hope so it's in the family
all right
U the bill
unamended House Bill
1392 the motion is
OTP moved by representative Gibbon
seconded by representative sidal with
the clerk please call the role chairman
Pearson yes representative long no
Representative disimon no representative
bfit
representative Nelson no representative
McMahon yes representative ball
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative
LC no representative Patrina will vote
no representative
Perez absolutely not representative
Greg representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond
no
five Y and 10
NOS I need a volunteer to write the
committee report we
need oh of course we do now the uh
motion is itl who wishes to move itl
you're going to write the report so
think
carefully q and themed Jey no I already
wrot one
who all right I'll I'll move thank you
representative long moves itl who second
second second
perz you can help him with this you know
you can give the Spanish subtitle
you can do that all right the motion
before us on House Bill 1392 is itl move
by representative long and seconded by
representative Perez and would the clerk
please call the role chairman Pearson no
representative long yes representative
disimon
yes representative
Bickford representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon no representative
ball
yes representative Panic no
Representative sidel
no representative LC yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Perez yes representative
Greg representative Gibbons no
representative
Raymond
yes 10 to five
itl
and representative uh long I believe
will write the committee report and
representative Gibbons will write The
Minority Report and get them to me
please uh pretty
soon don't be like the chairman and be a
day
late I just want to say that if it
wasn't already in statute my vote would
have been different but it's already in
statute so thank you very much for
all right this concludes the exec
session on House Bill 1392 as I've said
a couple of times today what we're going
to do next Tuesday is already listed in
the house calendar and will be again
this Friday the 27th is vacation have
fun be safe and then we will meet again
on March for 5th for a big exec session
thank you all drive safely please Mr
chairman yes ma'am may I say something
you may say something I'm really sad
that we are off of the week of my
birthday I'm turning 5 the week of
vacation uh unless there's an objection
we will have a birthday party on March
objection
yes our committee clerk uh our committee
our researchers should have dressed up
time